oh come on let's go
boom and we're live david goggins your
book is [ __ ] fantastic man this has
been my running partner the audio
version of it has been my running
partner for the last week
it's [ __ ] amazing man well i
appreciate that thank you well you guys
are doing something very unusual the
book is great i've read i've read it
like sat down red red but the the audio
book is really interesting right because
you and the gentleman you wrote it with
yeah adam adam schonick adam schonick
who who reads it then you come on and
talk about things in between so it's
more than just the book right it's the
book plus it's the book plus like a
podcast right yeah so how that came to
be man is um
as i was going through this book for the
last year
we would go through change stuff up have
so many stories man we went through
interviews from people so many stories
he would come back and read it to me
all my changes and when he read i'm like
man this guy has a great reading voice i
love his reading voice
and i started getting these different
ideas about doing it like you know what
maybe he can read and i can do my
podcast thing on the side and he can
like after each chapter in between
chapters make it real interactive type
of thing and that's kind of how it came
to be man at the beginning i gotta be
honest the beginning i was like who is
this [ __ ] talking for david
gardens i was gonna call dave like dick
you redo this why don't you do it why
are you but but it works right it really
does work yeah like as as it goes on and
i got also
it's very obvious that you and him are
good friends so when you guys are
talking then i don't mind him reading
for you as much for some strange reason
right i know it doesn't make any sense
well i want to say we're good friends
i'm i'm just joking adam that you can
hear me right now um he became a pain in
my [ __ ] ass during this process man
because you know he's just uh he's a
real anal guy you know he he helped out
a lot you know i'm a i'm a real raw
sadistic type of mindset and he uh he
helped me put that on paper man so i
gave him a lot of credit for that well
it it comes across the book is
outstanding and you know it's it's it's
more than just sitting like sitting
across you and you telling your story is
one thing but this long detailed history
of how you became to be the person you
became
i think it's very educational for people
because they can realize like oh he
wasn't always this guy
right this is what's [ __ ] up about
people like you see a guy who's like you
who runs i mean how many ultra marathons
did you run in a row you read some
insane
in a row just stop and think about that
ladies and gentlemen eight hundreds
means eight 100 mile races
eight weekends in a row a 100 mile race
will put you out for [ __ ] six months
right you know when you ran eight of
them eight weekends what's the [ __ ] it's
a [ __ ] insane accomplishment it was
nuts you think about a person like that
you think of them as in this like static
fully formed version right you don't
usually get to see and especially
someone like you who you went into so
much depth about your rise and fall and
rise and fall it wasn't like a straight
linear process between you getting
inspired and you becoming this bad
[ __ ] no it wasn't like um
what's that show called um
that will smith plays
that that black guy who kind of makes it
in um in the financial world
a pursuit of happiness i never saw that
yeah it's a great movie it wasn't like
pursuit of happiness man like like with
a guy who struggles and he and he gets
over it and he makes it yeah i feel on
my ass i i thought i got the top mount
everest and my neighbors just [ __ ]
slide right underneath me man i was like
god dawg i start from scratch again
scratch became my friend
literally man so you know that's that's
how you put in the book man just going
up going down going up just a real raw
version of how my life was and
it was so in-depth to go back through
your life with the fine-tooth comb
that i almost got embarrassed even put
it out there to people yeah that's what
i understand man like
even me right now to talk to you
i'm in the car for a [ __ ] hour
getting pumped up cause i'm i'm a shy
introverted leave me alone type of guy
like i'm still that [ __ ] who is
six years old you know at a play who
can't say his line because i know i'm
gonna stutter in front of five people so
i walk off the stage that's still me so
every day i'm fighting that dude so
people think oh my god man you're in a
podcast look so crazy so evil no i'm
trying to be locked into joe so my mind
isn't very off saying let's run out the
damn door because people are watching me
on the [ __ ] podcast i want to open
this damn door and get the hell out of
here man
so that's the real me so i'm not
sadistic man i'm focused on what i have
to do to stay locked into the game of
life and that's what and that's why i
tell people man i i go there i go there
that's one of the reasons why this book
is so good is because you're so honest
about your vulnerabilities and how you
overcome them and for people that see
someone who's a beast who's done great
things you just assume that they're
different than you right but then you
hear about your insecurities and your
pitfalls and all the things that went
wrong with you and you realized well god
damn it those are the same things that
go wrong with me like maybe i have that
inside of me and i've just never
summoned it right and i'll tell you this
i started really realizing that when i
started overcoming myself
i started getting around these real
alpha males these hard hard men
and i always put people way above me
when i was growing up like my god they
had to have a lot more than me to get to
where they're at
and a lot of them did
but once you get around the the best of
the best of the best people
you can kind of start breaking them down
and realizing man you you're just as
[ __ ] up as me like we all have but all
you did was you hit it better
your your your upbringing your mom and
dad your society the way you were raised
it hit it better than
than mine you weren't the only black kid
or there was like five in in a school
you know i can't hide going through buzz
i was only black you can't hide
but i started realizing just because i
look different than you a lot of you my
first cannot either so it started giving
me courage to watch some people that
were all have a story we all have a
jacked up life in one way or another
some of us don't have the guts to talk
about it though and that's where i found
the guts to talk about mine well there's
some there's purity in physical pursuits
right because it doesn't matter what
your social status is it doesn't matter
how people perceive you when it when it
comes down to how long can you stay in
that pool when it comes down to how far
can you run when it comes down to how
much can you push yourself past the part
where you want to quit how far can you
keep going there's a purity in that that
it did dissolve social order all that
[ __ ] all the what people think about
you goes out the window it's what who
who are you right now that's right who
are you right now that's a true
statement man and i look at it as
a psychological warfare
and that's where i started learning that
that life is one big psychological
warfare that you play on yourself
you play on yourself man
the most important conversation i ever
had with is with myself
and the [ __ ] i was telling myself was so
[ __ ] up it was so wrong it was so
misguided
and other people start to write that
dialogue for you also
it starts to be what you say to yourself
every single day and i started creating
a whole nother warfare
a whole nother battle started becoming i
was like oh hang on a second coggins
you have these tools
do you have these tools your life was
basically the perfect
the perfect grounds for training for
where you need to go in your life all
the beatings all the all the bullying
all that you know you going through uh
learning disabilities all the struggles
it was the absolute perfect training
ground for you to go to where you need
to go and that's how i start looking at
my life versus what was me poopy pants
kick a rock down the street mentality it
was no
god just hooked you right the [ __ ] up he
hooked you right up man with the perfect
place you were training for the first 18
19 20 you were training for this stuff
man you have the advantage of everybody
else versus
my god
they're so above me
they came from a great family
mom and dad loved them they didn't have
to learn they didn't start they didn't
struggle no man your struggle is what
made you who you are now so i started
flipping this into a whole different i
started being a master of
what i was scared of i was scared of my
mind
and i became a literally a master of
that mind and that's what now from now
on it sets me apart from most people i
start diving into that well that is a
big part of the story is when you go
over your childhood and you know
your abusive father and then having this
great guy that was going to become your
stepdad and then he gets murdered it's
like right when you're about to get out
of it everything looks good boom then he
gets murdered it's like these things
really did sort of set you up to start
from scratch again and just go okay
roger that we start from scratch and now
you have that attitude you developed it
through
all of these horrible personal
experiences all the trials and
tribulations all the evil [ __ ] that
people try to do to you that sort of set
you up to be able to deal in a way that
a lot of people can't
well
i used to look at my life from a
different vantage point
and when you're when you're in all the
muck and you're just walking in muck and
walking in muck and walking the muck
you don't see that if you look off to
the [ __ ] left of the muck there's a
sidewalk brother
get off get off of it you have your head
down looking in this muck
once i saw the sidewalk got the sidewalk
i got a little break and i got a
different vantage point and then from
the sidewalk i found a cliff then i
found a mountain i got way up high on
top of my life and looked back down on
it and said okay
i gotta figure this out man
i'm not going anywhere i'm starting to
lie i'm starting like so when you have a
messed up foundation i started lying
about everything i wanted people to like
me i wanted to be accepted in some
society of life some social society and
i
i said man this isn't the right way i
messed up here i messed up here i messed
up everywhere
and so i realized the worst thing that
happened to me is i lost myself i never
had myself i never found myself had no
self-esteem
so i knew through working out and
through learning because it took a lot
for me to learn also i started finding
self-esteem once i found that
that's when doors started opening up i
started i stopped caring about people
that what they thought being judged wow
if i say this if i started right now are
you gonna make fun of me i stopped
caring about that and that's my life
started really changing for me slowly
but surely that
that's such an important point when
you're talking about the working out
because a lot of people when they think
about working out they think of it as
being a physical thing right no
no
i did it for mental yeah people always
say my god like no
don't don't look at it like i didn't
care about losing weight i don't care
about being the fastest person i think
about i wasn't making the olympics i
wasn't going to pros i could barely read
and write when i was in a junior in high
school i wasn't going anywhere
i saw working out as a way for me to
build calluses on my mind
i had to callous over the victim's
mentality so
i watched these movies i you know i
talked about rocket last time i was on
here
i always equated training
to mental toughening
like it always looked brutal people
waking up early and doing all these
things and look it looks horrible it's
like wow i gotta start doing that not to
get better bigger and stronger but that
is what's gonna build me that looks
uncomfortable that looks brutal and
getting up early i don't want to do that
so i made this long list of things i
don't want to do
and through that i found myself i
started like i'm like you guys aren't
doing this [ __ ] in high school you guys
aren't getting up at five o'clock in the
morning running over here in this golf
course
so i started seeing myself very
differently than the average human being
i was like hold on a second
i have something they don't have
and that's when i started to develop
these things through working out it was
this great
never-ending work ethic
and through work ethic i develop
self-esteem now is this something that
you learned is this something you
learned yourself from from exercise
yourself or is it something you had read
or heard about like what made you equate
this doing this and doing these
difficult things physically to mental
toughness to being this is the
discipline that you need in order to get
your life out of the situation you're in
so i never read anything you know i i
could barely read you know so
i wasn't reading back then
i just saw i watched a lot of movies and
i was really big into visualization
and um i always equated working out to
struggle
and i struggled my whole life but i ran
from it
so i started realizing man i got to
start facing the struggle and i got to
be mentally strong for the struggle
so that's why i started coming up with
like i i'm training for life
mentally i'm training for life i'm not
training for like
to live 400 pounds and i found out on my
own pretty much is that through this
through through discipline through
self-discipline through repetition do
tons of repetition the same thing that
you don't want to do and that's that's
the key thing through repetition of
things you don't want to do you develop
mental like
like an armor for your mind start to
armor your mind cause your mind's like
okay we suffer we suffer every day it's
what we do we do stuff that sucks every
day so then when the suck stuff comes
you're ready for it and that's how i
started coming up you know i just
started being very uncomfortable and now
it's like just a way of life
it's a crazy thing to figure out though
it's like that you figured it out and
you didn't just figure it out you
embraced it like when you were talking
about your senior year of high school
when you're talking about
your your mirror being your
accountability mirror like you had a
radical shift like you just decided to
not be a [ __ ] loser and to start
tightening up and start holding yourself
accountable and and get ready for things
so i had this my whole life i mean i
don't know if people believe in god or
what i don't care what you believe in
there's been this unrelenting voice in
my head we all have this voice
it's the right or wrong voice
and a lot of times that voice guides us
into comfort
and
my voice guided me to comfort a lot but
i have this other voice i heard my whole
life saying hey [ __ ] what are
you doing nah man we gotta go over here
we have to go over here to to that rock
pile over in the [ __ ] corner where
nobody's at that's that's where
victory's at
were over in that corner so this voice
was giving me all these answers not i
wasn't real smart kid growing up but i
had this crazy voice in my head saying
over there is where the [ __ ] answers
are and i won't listen to it because
over there was pain
over there was me looking in the mirror
over there was me being accountable for
all these things that went through my
life even though people put them on me
it's not mine to own
and i didn't want to go over there by
myself
but i had to and this voice was guiding
me there out it's god whatever you want
to call it uh but that's what that's
what it was in me do you think that's
just what you when you separate yourself
from your ego and what you were your
insecurities and all you like if you
were giving yourself advice you would
say that's what the thing is to do so do
you think that's what it was like your
subconscious or though you stripped away
from all the [ __ ] when you couldn't
lie to yourself because it's a voice in
your head that's exactly it it's exactly
it because it knew it knew i was a
character
i was trying to find myself through a
character i was making different
hairstyles and sagging my pants and
i was off i was off man i was
i was a clown i was a clown and and i
was like this is not this is not where
you're supposed to be in life man it's
ugly when you look in that dirty mirror
and you're trying to do a new hairstyle
to go to school you know i had a
hairstyle one time where i shaved the
top of my head you know how old men had
the hair like leaving their head yeah
yeah so i went to school with hair on
the side of my head and in my back and i
shaved the the whole top of my head i
just i went to school like that you know
and then i had like what did the kids
say
i wanted to i don't remember what they
said but i was just a funny dude you
know so that was my thing i was the
funny dude that came into school like
criss cross came out when i was in high
school so my pants were backwards i seen
what i passed backwards sagged down past
my ass crack shirt turned backwards with
a toothbrush in my mouth with the
reverse part the reverse part is your
head is shaved and you have some hair
on top just a little piece of hair
versus like a like a part right through
hair the part was on a bald head
so it was just i i i would sit at home
instead of studying i would think about
what can i do to impress a [ __ ]
at school
and that became my life
and that is
it's a
long road to hoe to get to the guy who
says now you'll never smile on any
podcast looks so serious i look at that
[ __ ] i'm like you [ __ ] have no
idea
who i am who where i've come from to get
here today you could have probably been
an entertainer like you probably because
you were doing all that kind of [ __ ] i
have some jokes joe
i got some jokes yeah you do so
what people read in this book can't hurt
me it's a sad story it's a horrible
story it's a tragic story it's a story
that made me who in the day but
you have to learn to laugh at yourself
too once you once you go through that
[ __ ] yeah now so there's a lot of parts
in there there's a lot of me against a
lot of white people you know
and i have a routine that i won't do so
people who hire me to speak i'm not
going to do the routine i often do it
sometimes think about it i was a 36
black guy to go through still training
okay no matter how many people out of
probably looking at um probably 11 12
to make it through probably 13 000 seals
i was probably the 36 i was a 36 black
guy to make it through and over since
like the like 1940s you know you're
looking at almost 70 years wow yeah so
you know you know you know do the math
on that so there's not a lot of black
guys and so i take that and i make a
nice comedy skit out of that [ __ ]
you know like like like the first time
they tied me up and threw me it's called
drown proofing yeah so i'm negative
boring as hell you know me too oh i'm
related to that big time yeah she wanted
a few white boys man they're that
negative boy you sit like a rock
and that's hard so imagine them getting
your hands and feet tying your ass up
and throwing in the [ __ ] water and
say swim
ah it was like throwing a cat in the
water with [ __ ] brick on them so i
was just losing my [ __ ] mind so it's
so many things i had to get over you
know and i found humor i found humor in
my suffering
i was like [ __ ] what are you
doing out here goggins like this is
crazy like you're you're literally
trying to
reinvent the wheel but i was trying to
reinvent my mind
i was trying to reinvent my mind and i
used every single tactic possible to do
that
i didn't want to live you know live in
this world where i was a fake human
being anymore
and i was tired of blaming everybody for
where i was at
my dad beat me this happened i mean my
dad ran prostitutes man my dad literally
snatched the soul out of my mom like my
mom is still battling like after my mom
left my dad
and that's why i'm talking about in the
book she got married three times for a
total of six months
you know i don't go there and i'm not
gonna talk about the guys she married so
this woman was she's beautiful she's
she's so smart all this stuff man this
guy literally stripped her soul away and
i was a young kid watching it
and i had no soul to begin with
and my my brother he has a story that he
could write eight books
you know my dad just came through and
just washed us all clean
so to
to to come around he died about four
years ago four or five years ago not for
sure i didn't go to the funeral but i
forgave him
so i saw my dad through an
eight-year-old's eye so so we left when
i was eight
and then at 22 i went back
to see him through a grown man's eyes
and he was the same person i remembered
but i had to you can't live with hate
you cannot move forward as much as that
guy tried to ruin all of our lives
that's where i came from i had to figure
out the origin of where i started from
so when i was going back through my life
trying to fix who i am the [ __ ] up
person i was
like if your knee hurts it's usually not
your [ __ ] knee that's hurting
it's something else man like it could be
a tight quad it could be the right leg
if it's the left leg you got to find out
the origin of where all this [ __ ] began
and i it was him so i had to go back to
where you know
my roots and the origin of all this
happen and it's hard to do that did you
make peace with him i made big piece
with
so we didn't have a peaceful
conversation we you know we we we left
very animal he's a he's a he's a vicious
man
he he was a vicious man i mean medieval
[ __ ] so
i had become a medieval [ __ ] at
that time i was 22 and i was the big boy
and
so i was no longer the guy who was
afraid it was not like hey i want to
kill you type of [ __ ] and we were
sitting at denny's
after an all-night skate or whatever the
hell you know he owned bars and skating
rings like that and
so we were sitting down and we kind of
got into it and i just kind of left
and but i had to make peace with it in
myself
i i could not hold on to that hate cause
hold on to that hate was half the reason
why i kept falling into the same pattern
of failing
i had to get i had to start dumping off
some baggage i had to start figuring out
me
through him and that's all he was there
for he was the origin i had to figure
him out figure out why he was so evil to
my mom to me my brother and i had to
start studying him like a lot of people
have situations where someone does
something and we all attack that person
like like on the media if someone does
something wrong everybody now is [ __ ]
perfect and we now judge this guy
i don't judge him i don't judge anybody
what i do is i start studying them why
did they do that
not in a judging way i want to learn
from you and what'd you get out of your
dad i got that he was he grew up rough
he had he was very insecure had a lot of
kids
and
his insecurities just trickled over
onto us
so yeah he jacked us up real good but he
never fixed himself so if you never fix
yourself
the next person in line is going to get
the wrath and we were next in line
you know his his first wife you know
killed herself or whatever happened and
you know got burned up in the house or
something some craziness and there's a
lot of stuff that goes on there that i
didn't put in the book because i don't
feel like going to court yeah but um
yeah that's uh it was it was a lot of
stuff
you know one of the great parts about
this book is that you you detail exactly
what was going through your mind in
terms of like your weaknesses and how
you had failed and and then
you it's not just one time like you you
do the thing in high school where you
get your [ __ ] together and then you join
the military and then you wind up
getting fat again
and then when you go when you have to
lose what is 106 pounds in three months
yep to to to qualify for seal training
yep that's insane yeah because when i
realized at that time once again i
failed again i thought so what you're
talking about is i took this asvab test
you know i didn't know how to read and
write pretty much in high school i was
like a fourth grade reading level
and i took that test a few times
and i finally passed it and when i
passed it i actually drove my car to the
to the daggone airport and watched
planes take off
because i was like i'm gonna be on one
of those planes one day going to air
force boot camp so i i never
i always fix the things on the surface
so if i couldn't read and write learn to
read and write
i i would always fix these things on the
surface level and so whenever something
hard would would
like like raise ugly head
i didn't have any kind of tools to
handle it like man i thought i fixed
this already man but no i didn't go deep
into the dungeon of my soul to say okay
what is making you a quitter
what is making you a weak man what is
making you afraid
and so
that's why i kept on quitting and going
back to start or not knowing how to get
through hard times and that's why i was
telling people i'm not a theorist
i didn't study like you know i didn't
study a [ __ ] book
i literally put myself in a fire
repeatedly like a sword you put a sword
in the fire repeatedly and repeat if you
keep on doing that you're going to get a
nice sword and you keep on beating it
you got to beat the [ __ ] out of it
and that's what i am
yeah i i became that i i said okay we
can't quit we got to figure out why you
are this [ __ ]
why are you this [ __ ] man what is wrong
with you what's going on here so i kept
on putting the sword back in the dagger
on fire and i just beat it harder and i
beat it harder before i knew i started
realizing
all right man the brain is starting to
get hard
the brain is starting to get hard i'm no
longer a theorist i'm now a practitioner
i put it in hell i dissected it while
it's in hell because you can't dissect
anything in a normal environment you
can't dissect anything in 72 degree
weather
you must put it in the [ __ ] freezer
and freeze the [ __ ] out of it and then
you dissect it dissect it when it's
miserable dissect the brain when all
this thinking about is i need to get out
of here man
i want to get out of the [ __ ] freezer
open the door
and he said nah
five more seconds man five more seconds
in the freezer and that's when you start
to pick that brain apart and that's what
all this stuff did to me i kept on
putting myself back into the freezer or
the fire and beating the [ __ ] out of
myself
mentally and physically
before i knew it this is what happened
wow
it's an interesting way to self-teach
yes like most people that
you know you talk to that are
disciplined
they
you know they have something that they
read that inspired them they have
certain people that they look up to
there's certain you know coaches that
taught them there's certain important
moments in their life but for you it's a
system of failure and and
reflection and then rebooting that's it
repeated failure
and people think a lot of times it
taught me that i'm angry oh my god you
sound so angry you cut so much oh my god
why you cuss so much why are you so
crazy
if you read my book i cannot explain my
life by saying hey it was a merry
[ __ ] christmas man no it wasn't i
want you i want you to go there with me
i'm taking you there with me
i'm a storyteller i want to take your
ass down paradise where i so the house i
lived in buffalo new york that i got my
ass beat every day funny we lived on
paradise road
and it was anything but [ __ ] paradise
so i want you to go there with me you
want to learn from me let me take your
ass home let me take you there so that's
the whole thing about it man we're
scared to dive into
our lives what made us who we are
the beautiful people that we are we're
all jacked up in so many ways that's the
beauty of us
that's the beauty of me
i'm jacked up
but i figured out my own little process
on how to get unjacked up and how to i'm
not gonna get the same you know i'm not
gonna get the same way you're gonna get
there you may get there by going
pointing to point b
i might go point c to d to e to f i want
to be there the same way you are just a
little harder that's how i train my
brain
so it's just different i'm a different
thinker
when you stop and think about all the
different times that you did have to
reboot and how you you you found like
new goals and you found new inspiration
you fired up a new discipline and you
became stronger and harder and you got
one of the things that people always
look for in life they look for a point
where they can rest yes oh i'm going to
retire
you know like people love they love that
expression the golden years they love
that expression yeah
they love the they love the idea of
struggle as long as it ends and then
when it ends they're going to have a
nice comfortable spot it must end the
suffering must end yeah you should relax
man you've done so much that's right
you've really done so much but this
the idea of reaching this golden year
is is it's a very flawed idea because
it's an idea that you're gonna you're
gonna work hard but then you're gonna
reach the finish line but there's no
finish line no it doesn't exist
that's the scary thing about life my
friend that is a scary thing right and
that's what fatigues me people go man
why don't you ever smile there's no
[ __ ] end my friend
there's no end
there's no end i know that you're you're
you're going to meet cam haynes after
this yes sir and listen please if you
guys run put a number of that miles that
you're going to run and leave it at that
do not say
let's see who quits because you will
both die because that's a hard man he is
a hard man cameron haynes is a hard man
he will run until you die or he dies
he's a hard man dude he doesn't he does
those 240s he does ultra he's a sick
[ __ ] and see those are the guys i'm
looking for yeah that's a scary do you
want the two of you guys you need to
pick a number i know whatever you get i
think you guys are going to run 35 miles
yeah you're gonna do good yeah 35 is a
good number yeah we've been texting back
and forth trying to make it you know
trying to make it sensible you know yeah
so we don't go off the chain because if
one of you [ __ ] wakes up and
has a good strong espresso i know [ __ ]
it let's do 300. it's gonna be on
it's gonna be a long day man no
that's it yeah you you know this new
race that they're doing where they're um
you run for one hour you run like as
many and then you have like a bell rings
and then you sit down for a little bit
you know what i mean like you there's
like a
4.17 mile thing yep it's that sick [ __ ]
what was it the guy's name that created
that like i did the barclay marathon yes
you're talking about last yeah yeah this
is crazy [ __ ]
so he had people running for days and
days and days he invited me out there
for this race yeah i actually got into
the barclay last year but couldn't do it
because of the book so i'm supposed to
do it this year
but now you know we'll see again how the
schedule goes but yeah that that's a
sick
sick man i've done a couple of his races
and like he has one called strolling jim
i actually won that one in 2016. but
he's a he's a sick man what is this
scrolling
this is probably easiest race it's like
it's like through the back country of uh
tennessee it's a 41 mile race on the
road it's one of the first you know
ultra marathons out there ever
and my mom lives in nashville so it's
like an hour drive i went up there and
it was like when my first race is back
after me being all sick and jacked up
for so long and i got lucky had a good
race and i happened to want it you know
you were talking about psoas muscle yeah
we have this thing now that we got what
does that call the pro pro so right so
right have you ever used one i have it
also i i saw it in there that that
little black contraption yeah that hard
plastic thing yeah phenomenal it's evil
man yeah yeah it's good it's amazing i
started getting tightness in that when i
was running a lot like i'd never gotten
tightness in that area before yeah it
seems like that's a running thing right
it's a running thing and also a very
stressed thing
you know if you're real stressed out man
like for me like i talked about the
origin where like where things start my
body was so wrapped tight i didn't know
where like where to start yeah so i
started with the psoas muscle so that's
a real good spot well the problem with
these races is pro the problem with
people like you that's the problem with
these races like if you get you and
another you right and they're in there
together like you [ __ ] are
gonna kill each other it's a long day
it's a long day it's a long day it's a
long day
because if they're doing a last man
standing type deal right yeah like the
first person to quit yeah it's a it's a
real long day man i mean i've been up i
got a couple hills under my belt man i
know how to fail for 130 hours to move
yeah and i know how to self-motivate a
lot of [ __ ] don't know how to
self-motivate man like we like to put
the headphones on like before the big
game and listen to the music yeah
what the [ __ ] did you do when the
headphones come off bro it's you in your
own mind right i know how to do that
that's that's the hard part do you ever
listen to music when you run never never
i told you jamie's cheating he has that
video i got i thought you might have
seen it but he talks about like running
with music no what did you say i find it
find the video we'll play it we might
not be able to play it we get is it
somebody else's content
i actually um but i did
during my last pull-up record
i listened to you know that song um from
rocky 1
round 14
when rocky gets knocked down the corner
i listened to this two minutes and 13
seconds long i listened on repeat for 17
hours christmas [ __ ]
merry christmas man 17 hours man i went
to such a dark dark evil i have a
picture in my hand in the book
i was in a dark
i went to this i went to a place man
that i'm like i can do anything here we
gotta live here for a while
because i kept on feeling that wreck i
go like i don't want to see a pull-up
bar again
i mean like i did 67 000 pulls man like
this is my throat i can't i don't want
to see no pull up so it's like i'm i'm
doing this come hello high water man
i broke it out it's just let me hear
this let me hear let's play this
so i never trained with music
there's a reason why i don't do that
the music's not going to always be there
the tv the distractions
all these external things
i'm in the gym right now with all this
live music people needed to get fired up
they needed to stay motivated they need
to stay in the fight they needed to just
go in the gym
to do whatever they're gonna do
what do you do when you have no external
motivation
it's about the internal
what do you say to yourself
how are you going to fire yourself up
what's that flame inside of you that
keeps you going
let that keep you going not this
and when you're doing this the whole
time you're doing this you're doing some
of the hardest chin-ups you can do you
got a chain around your neck right
folks that are just listening and you're
pulling down on ropes you're doing
chin-ups on it looks like taped up ropes
yes sir that's what it is yeah those are
grip
that's like jiu jitsu guys do a lot of
those yes i was uh i spoke to the
university of alabama and they were in
there you know most you know most these
athletes man they got to get hyped so
that music is blaring yeah i'm like man
once that [ __ ] comes off
and you get popped in your [ __ ] mouth
your headphones are on the sidelines
brother
what's gonna happen
yeah you can say to yourself then so
that's that's how i train my mind man i
i trade my mind i don't get popped in my
mouth man i'm gonna get popped in the
back of an alley one day man running
around doing what i do
and there's gonna be no music yeah you
better fight you're gonna figure it out
i told you jamie's cheating
when i first started running people said
do you run with music and i know running
it's cheating when you have music on
it's cheating you're cheating you listen
to music but now i listen to music all
the time but more than i listen to music
i listen to books yeah
books on tape uh audiobooks and yours is
like i said has been the last two weeks
has been my running partner well i
appreciate that man you're supposed to
be phenomenal man it's phenomenal and
you're doing this kind of independently
right yeah so what i did man is i pissed
off a lot of people
i was um i
so in 2012 i got an offer for my book
for 30 thousand dollars
i said you can go [ __ ] yourself
you know what hell i went through
brother so then everybody was like you
know we don't see a market for a black
guy ultra runner fat guy who uh couldn't
read
like uh you know 15 percent of america's
black you know i won't see any [ __ ]
you know people buying your book
they think only black people will buy
your book there's some ignorant people
out there man everybody that follows me
is white
i don't have a black
i have like three black followers man
event was just left he's furious
he's a big fan he's black yeah he's like
he's like an unusual species out there
man
like and so i'm sitting there walking
around going man you don't even know who
like everybody talk to is white like you
know it's the ignorance of the world and
i'm in these meetings here and this kind
of stuff so now 2018 i get a 300 000
offer
for a first-time author so i'm sitting
back you know
i'm like my god man you know i used to
make like [ __ ] sixty thousand dollars
a year you know this is the biggest
payday yet
and i started thinking i took that one
second i talked about the one second
decision a lot about what i went through
my life what i've done
and i was like you know what
i struggled so hard in my life i went
through so much that the biggest trophy
i own now
is that book
the biggest trophy i don't know is not
the book itself it's what's in the book
it's what like i don't give a [ __ ] if
that sells one copy
honest to god man like like my what i
did and that's what i hope people
understand your life in the journey you
put yourself through
there's no there's nothing more than
that and that's all i want people to do
is realize
that you have to struggle
you have to struggle the bigger the
struggle the bigger the peace the bigger
the suffering the more peace i'm not
just saying this because you're here but
this book is valuable this book is very
valuable it's valuable to people like
anybody that you know i mean biographies
are very always valuable when you get to
see the mindset of a person who's done
things that you haven't done you get to
understand like that they're overcoming
sort of the same
sort of situations in their mind that
you are same insecurities and pitfalls
but yeah everybody's going through it
man yeah everybody that's that's
something i say i'm blessed that way
that
my story
there's no color involved in it
it's a human story about struggle
and i happen to be in so many different
situations that so many people can
relate to about struggle
that
i guarantee you mark my word you read
that book there will be
a section of that book that resonates
with you hardcore it will make you think
if if you're not ready to think about
your life
and think about
you know where you can be and think
about what you haven't done the book's
not for you if you're not ready to sell
to really self-reflect and hold yourself
accountable for where you're at and
where you're not
the book is not for you is real i've
read a lot of self-help books and i've
listened to a lot of self-help books on
tape too and a lot of just some of them
that i have to shut off i have to shut
off a quarter way and i feel like
someone's lying to me i just like you're
bullshitting me you're just saying
things this i'm not this doesn't
resonate with me it doesn't it's not
working right like i'll give it a chance
i'll give it a chance but if i'm you
know a half hour in two hours in it's
still the same nonsense i don't feel
anything right i'm getting itchy
listening to you
you know i just want to pull the
headphones off and i'll just kill it and
i'll stop it this is the total opposite
this one man i was i was go i was
running extra miles so i could stay with
the headphones on and the
the thing that i think is going to
happen with this book is people are
going to get it they're going to get a
hold of whether it's the audiobook or
their book book and they're going to
they're going to recommend it and then
it's going to spread like wildfire this
is a powerful book this is a real
self-help book this is like this is a
real one like it's not like uh someone
orchestrates this whole thing like what
i'm going to do is i'm going to become a
motivator i'm going to be i'm going to
be a personal influencer i'm going to be
that guy that goes out there and tells
people you can optimize your life here's
how you do it and there's so many of
those [ __ ] guys out there right yeah
that's not me man i know this one dude i
ran into him recently i ran into him at
this restaurant he's fat as [ __ ] he's
got this big old belly and i know he
does these these motivational things and
i'm looking at him i'm like what are you
talking about man like you're weak right
look at your body look at your own
temple look at your meat vehicle you're
carrying around this [ __ ] donut
around your waist it's just he was
eating shitty food and he looked soft
and like wake up [ __ ] so many people
are doing that now man how many people
are talking this noise exactly and i see
them yeah i know them i'm not gonna say
names but i know them i'm like man dude
you know why my life is miserable right
now because i can't go on your show
right now your podcast if i didn't get
after it this morning
so i cannot talk to people
unless you're authentic unless i'm
authentic because i used to be the most
unauthentic [ __ ] on the planet
now i have this voicemail saying oh no
i'll call you up if i lie to you about
something even a white lie hey yo joe
guess what dude
i [ __ ] lied to you man like that
wasn't real like it would bother me that
badly now you know so another thing i
didn't what's funny about this book
stuff man i didn't set out to write a
book
like literally man when i was 24 years
old and a cow's fat spraying for
cockroaches eating donuts and drinking
milkshakes
i did not plan on doing this
all i wanted to do was change the
[ __ ] reflection in that dagger mirror
this is all just a box it's it's it's a
byproduct of
of that and that's that's the funny
thing about it like everybody's like oh
my god david goggles what you know what
tell you i'm like
what the [ __ ] that's why it works though
unbelievable
it works because you really did do it
you really did do all those things and
you show how you did it and you're not
using any [ __ ] theatrical jargon no
you're not you know you're you know
you're not saying a bunch of buzzwords
can you live the life of an actualized
person i can show you how and you look
at this guy talking he's got a neck like
a pencil and his
his body is just frail like you don't
even understand adversity you don't
understand overcoming this is not the
secret you know this isn't about the law
of [ __ ] attraction yeah there ain't
no attraction here brother
this ain't no attraction here man this
book is straight up yeah they love
nonsense yeah this is no nonsense man no
nonsense this is a real self-help book
man this is the real deal that's how you
self-help you're self-help by people
who've done it and you learn what they
did and you realize there's no shortcuts
right and then you learn to embrace that
no shortcut mentality and enjoy enjoy
the suffering and the grind of it and
what we talked about earlier there's no
[ __ ] finish line doesn't exist you
know what's funny about that is i have
people now so when i was in the worst
part of my life
those people want to bring you back in
those people's like like you can see who
you hang out with like when you're in
your worst and when you're trying to get
better with what makes it hard to get
better is that you are hanging around
people who like let's say you're an
alcoholic you hang around people who
drink
and i say you want to stop drinking
those people want to bring you back in
like i used to be this guy this guy who
was you know who wasn't worth anything
now those people who are still there
they're
16 17 18 30 years ago they're trying to
get you back there so the hardest part
you got gotta see who you're hanging out
with man
you gotta hang out with the people who
you wanna be like the most yeah people
will definitely drag you they'll jack it
down and especially if you around
someone who makes a lot of excuses and
they're always failing oh this is just
like they're they're the opposite of
inspiration they're like a vacuum 100
sucking it out of you why are you doing
that today man
why are you getting up again so early
why are you doing this why are you doing
this
the people you're hanging around will
suck the [ __ ] life out of you yeah
sometimes just gotta be alone man get
your [ __ ] in and then there's also
people that are gonna be around that are
always failing and they're always
[ __ ] up and then always coming to you
to try to get you to help them exactly
a giant burden yes never look in the
mirror and get their own [ __ ] together
they're always looking for external help
that's right always looking for a storm
people don't want to go in deep man all
the ants are inside of you
it's a very primitive way how like how
this book is written it's primitive
it's it's very barbarian it's how we all
think it's how it's it's how man once
walked the earth
and then we get all soft and all these
computers and [ __ ] we start going away
from
the the most powerful thing we have is
our [ __ ] brain it's our mind and we
don't use it anymore
so you know it's like everything has to
be so quick yeah you use your mind when
it comes to certain things right but
what you're saying is you don't use your
mind when it comes to enduring exactly
that is it you can't google that [ __ ]
right hey let me google how to suffer
no
that ain't gonna be in there bro
ain't gonna be in there
it could be in there
there's no answer it's not in there it
doesn't exist
find some water real cold and what's
interesting is that that is a mind thing
and people think of mind things they
think of calculating mathematics
literature no no no no no there's many
aspects to the mind that's it don't
overthink it yeah don't overthink it put
your shoes on lace them up
that's all you got to do my friend
don't overthink the process yeah but see
what because you've overcome and because
you've accomplished so much now that
even when you you talk about that moment
of like embracing that suck like you see
the big ass smile on your face like
you've you've got a total different
approach to it than the average person
oh yeah the average person you're
talking to them about doing chin ups for
24 hours or anything [ __ ] crazy they
don't look at they're like oh
there's like a a negative a doom feeling
that's the thing about it man i talk
about my book open-mindedness
what separates me from a lot of people
is they go into an
a daunting task
and the task is overwhelming like when i
heard the pull-up break was 4020
pull-ups and i was talking about
breaking this record
people are like oh my god
i went right to a pen and paper like
what are you doing i'm doing the math
man
what are you talking about i'm open mind
to the fact that okay if i do five
pull-ups on the minute for so many hours
i can get some pull-ups in how much time
do i have to rest i was breaking the
math down you have to be open-minded to
the possibilities that i can do this
once you shut your mind down to the
possibility that it can be achieved
there's no way it can happen so that's
why my my eyes and my body light up
about things because i know that if
you're in a fight you have to attack
you have to keep attacking
the enemy has to know he is not going to
give up you must break the soul of
whatever the [ __ ] is in front of you
that's what i realized i was never
breaking the soul of anything in front
of me
so that's why i came with the thing
called taking souls in my book
i started to devise ways to break
a soul
of a human being of an object of
whatever's in front of me if you keep on
attacking something nothing wants to
stand in front of anything
that is relentless
nothing
the taken soul part of the book is
really interesting because uh you talked
about like the the mind shift that you
had when you were in buds yes sir yeah
that was that's an intense part of the
book it's it is uh
that's when a lot of stuff started
clicking man
i started watching those instructors on
the side you know there's there's
three shifts there's eight instructors
three shifts because you know the guys
going through through hell week they're
up all day and all night for 130 hours
this is the promised land of mental
hardening for me i love this place and
you have the instructors who you know
you know they've been there done that
now they're instructing you so they do
their eight hour shift they have their
parkas on it's usually cold coffee
drinking their coffee
and they're beating the crap out of us
and when i started realizing i started
playing mind games and i was like you
know what i bet these [ __ ]
are looking at us
judging themselves about when they were
going through hell week about let me see
i'm looking at goggins right now i was
better than him i was bearing that guy
bearing that [ __ ] over there and i was
like
okay
okay you gotta judge me right
so it's not gonna do to you so what i
started doing was i got my boat crew
boat crew too it's in the book it's a
great great story said come here guys
you can't break boat crude you can't
break broke crew 2. so
it's wednesday is wednesday and
everybody's broken everybody's beat up
man and like this you start moving like
a robot everybody's like just kind of
just trying to get through helbig now
and your energy zap and they know
wednesdays like that over the hump i
love that you talked about that in the
book too that they put it in your head
wednesday you're gonna be tired oh yeah
and that's another thing they they tell
you how you're supposed to feel
so
you are feeling that way i was like ah
don't let these [ __ ] tell you
how you supposed to feel no it's day one
[ __ ] this is hour one so i was
getting my broker all jacked up i said
we're gonna take these [ __ ]
souls so when they had us doing this
simple thing that guys are struggling
with broker two is just lost in the
[ __ ] boat near yelling yeah he can't
[ __ ] hurt us can't hurt boat crew too
and i looked on the instructor's faces
and it looked like someone had just
[ __ ] with their soul
and i looked at my guys my broker and i
said hey guess what those [ __ ]
aren't [ __ ] tonight because we own
space in their [ __ ] head
we own space they're gonna think about
us tonight they could think about how
they're killing boners that's right
how
how on wednesday are these guys doing
this and screaming out you can't hurt
people too we were we were bringing the
fight we were attacking so so when you
keep on doing that guess what people
start doing
i ain't [ __ ] with these guys no more
so bro crew 2 got a lot more sleep roku
2 just became that broke like hey
because we just kept charging and we
started fueling off of that we started
fueling out the fact that man it takes
one second of energy
to steal everybody's
and then you have all the energy you
need
that's all you need you need to look at
someone's eyes you know how this when
you fight somebody you broke that
[ __ ] he's like oh god man i
don't want to go back the next round and
you feel like my god i can fight all day
i can fight all day long that's what
taking souls is
but you have to have the will
the heart the courage
to go
that distance when you're exactly jacked
up you have nothing left to give
and give more
that is an interesting thing about the
mind is that you can find inspiration
and when you find inspiration when you
get charged up all of a sudden you have
energy that's right it's right it's
weird i talked about in the book also is
about
i learned how to control
my adrenals
if you know how you know how you get
that fight or flight response when you
get to move real quick yeah and you know
i i started learning the mind a lot how
to get myself jacked
extremely fast like in a horrible
environment when everybody's miserable
i learned how to really find strength in
the misery
when everybody's suffering everybody's
all poopy past and their mentality's
down and everything i started just like
my god this is where i shine
and i started using all that misery
for tons and tons of tons of drive and
motivation to
to then lead people further
because you can get a lot of power
through misery and once people see that
my god cognizance is [ __ ] going
then everybody says roger that let me
get my [ __ ] and go too
so i started realizing that if you can
just find strength just a little bit
longer you'll have a crew of people
following you along the way
and that is another thing that no one
can ever teach you because you you're
going to have to learn that on your own
you're going to have to figure out how
to pull that energy out of your mind on
your own there's not
there's there's no book you can read now
all sudden i have it i've got the
technique now i know how to do it yeah
no it's it's a a grind that you have to
start and finish on your own you have to
take great pleasure in the fact that no
one wants to be with the [ __ ] you're at
right now
great pleasure in that almost makes you
know it has to bring a passion out of
you it has to bring something very very
weird out of you man like
you know people don't really understand
what that is when you're in the worst
environment possible the worst situation
possible and everybody's looking like
god man i hope this ends
and you see that
time slows down and you see that you're
you're feeling that
everybody has that look on their face
like god that's got to go i don't want
to be anymore have you ever gotten rabdo
wrapped on my lowest oh yes sir did you
get it yes sir yes sir when did you get
it i got it on my second pull-up record
attempt and i talked about it a little
bit in the book there um
and
i have sickle cell trait and a young kid
just died from rhabdo
from uh because sickle cell's not a good
thing obviously um and
rhabdo's a bad thing for having sickle
cell you have sickle cell trait but you
don't have the disease i don't have the
disease a buddy of mine died from it
when i was a kid really yeah
a guy used to fight with us to train
with
yeah he was always sick he'd have it get
sick his heart he'll be gone he'd be out
of the gym for months and he'd come back
and he'd just be trying to get his body
back in shape again
then he went up dying
he's a talented guy too
when you got it what did you have to do
so they put me to hospital for a while
um that's when my hand got real messed
up
and my fluids were extremely low and i
had done like i think i did 3 000
pull-ups
and they're like man your body is
wrecked up were you just not drinking
water while you're doing it i was
drinking water but not enough so i was
sipping this carbohydrate drink
and um
my calories were extremely low i didn't
know how much i was going to burn
through and you burn through an awful
lot of calories man doing that many
pull-ups so that many hours yeah and
with the repetition
with using the single points of just my
hands and my biceps my back
like my body was swollen like the
pillsbury doughboy
i mean it looked horrible
and um so
they kept me in there for a while but
how long probably about eight hours
i was about eight hours on ivs and stuff
like that so they just it's basically a
ton of drinks yeah
tons of fluid and they sent me home
though
so i went home that night
and how long did you wait before you
jump back at it
i think i was back on the pull-up bar
about a week and a half later
and then i broke the record six six
weeks later i broke the record jesus
christ
so when you when you did get back on the
pull-up bar
was how [ __ ] up was your body from
it was bad but what i do is like what
i've done through everything it which
isn't real smart i mean it works for me
so i'm not saying do this is i've
trained through a lot of my injuries
and i started developing i i started
doing that in buds and still training
because i instill training you know they
know you guys start from day one or they
just kick you out so i started from day
one enough so my third time going
through i was really jacked up well you
went you had pneumonia yeah i had
pneumonia and i had really bad stress
fractures
so my stretch fracture so i was
literally i would put a sock on and then
duct tape my foot all the way up to the
top of my or to the middle of my ankle
or to my calf and because my stress
fracture was so bad so like the pivot
point between my ankle and my shin i
just cast that all the way up
and so i went through for several months
for a few months with stretch fractures
what was crazy about that is they healed
by the time i got to third phase my
stress reactions were healed wow and i
don't even know how rhyme or reason
behind it i ran on them a few months
later they were healed wow so i don't
know what that means just push through
the agony and eventually your body just
said this crazy [ __ ] is not gonna stop
it's true statement yeah it's weird a
lot of my injuries i've just pushed
through and they've uh
i duct tape it up i mean have you ever
had to have surgery on any of them no
just heart just a couple heart surgeries
but um none of my actual physical body
and what was your heart surgery for
again you talked about this before yeah
asd i had a hole in my heart yeah so
which is even more ridiculous yeah
that's what we talked about that too man
they uh they they took me off and
studied me for a while
so they realized that my god
i shouldn't even be in the military i
wasn't even qualified to be in the
military at the hole in my heart
you know let alone being special
operations where you jumping on planes
and stuff like that so i was i was lucky
how'd they seal that up so they went in
with a helix patch
and um you know through my femoral
artery femoral artery and they went
through put a patch and they realized
you know i missed like three or four
years of a military career because this
heart surgery wow yeah so i was i was
off of jump status dive status i was
just uh so that's what i talked about
recruiting so much i i stayed in
recruiting for like three or four years
and um you know i became like a navy
city recruiter when i was uh
you know doing this for a while so i got
extended there because the heart surgery
and
other than that you never had to have
any other surgeries
um no meniscus no nothing no no that's
crazy no and i've had some
jacked up injuries
let's see how i grew up
you know like i talked about in the book
my dad didn't believe in taking me by
the hospital
like that's just how it was man it was
it was barbarian stuff man but
you know you learn to deal with it and
you live it
you're fine you get hurt mris oh yeah
get everything checked out matter of
fact man i was terrified mri machine for
a long time i was claustrophobic
i was like man that's
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot
behind that man but yeah i've i've been
checked out a lot i've had uh
so like i said like six years ago i
started stretching out like i thought i
was dying i couldn't even get out of bed
so all that stretching out was from
pretty much all these injuries i had
that i never really fixed
and my body got knotted up and more
knotted up and more knowledge i mean
it's going to heal
one way or another it's going to heal
and when it heals and i can heal right
it's going to heal all jacked up and
crooked yeah so i'm a crooked jacked up
dude man but i can still get it done
it's amazing that you haven't had like
knee surgeries or anything like that
consider all the running you've done my
left knee right now isn't it's no joke
so like i say origin of pain
my right foot is messed up because of my
left knee
so right now i'm i'm i'm taking care of
my left knee knees getting a lot better
now but
don't worry cameron haynes i will still
be [ __ ] out there running with your
ass i'm not gonna get out of it buddy so
if you're listening [ __ ] i will
see you this weekend
merry christmas
all right just so you know brother merry
christmas i'll see you soon
you don't know what's wrong with the
knee you have no idea it's from
stretching so basically stretching yeah
so my whole because my body was in in
such bad alignment
from just what i did to it
that now i'm in this huge stress routine
and my body's getting back into
alignment so your muscles like i was a
power lifter man like i i grew these
huge muscles and i'm this small guy and
i just and from the stress of my body
going through three health weeks and
also my body scout became one knot
so as things start to open up
joints start to hurt things start to
hurt and i'm like god so it's been this
big long process so i'm faster in better
shape than ever
my organs work better i'm healthier than
ever but i have these little tweaks here
these little tweaks there from the fact
that i am now my body was locked into
position
from these muscles being so tight now
what do you weigh now about 182 183 and
you were at like 300 plus pounds when
you're at your fattest right my fattest
when i weighed in for the military i
don't know what my fattest was but when
i weighed in
on that scale when steven sauzio hit
that scale on me man it was 297.
and he's like brother you gotta lose 106
pounds i was like [ __ ] this
what are you talking about
oh how's that possible so anyway it's
just you know not a lot of time that's
the crazy thing they didn't give you
three months to lose that 33 pounds a
month is a lot of [ __ ] weight plus a
few almost impossible and that's what i
thought that's what i thought but see
you see the person now i was 175 pounds
in high school so i was a skinny guy in
high school so i made myself big
i'm a small bone person so it didn't it
wouldn't trust me it was hard
it was hardest thing i've ever done in
my life
but what did people think around you
when they saw you three months later
you're 100 pounds lighter my mom
couldn't believe it because my mom so i
was living in indianapolis in the end at
the time
and so i was
trying to study for this asvab test
again that you know i got to take it
again going to the navy and i'm out here
trying to lose weight and i'm you know
working for this company spraying for
cockroaches and all sort of crap and i
would lay in her pond
in [ __ ] november in indiana
just lay in her pond i was like i'm
going to bust i got to get hard you know
so i would lay in the pond get out of
the pond and go for a run
just all wet cold like my like the dad
gone shirt would just freeze up from ice
and [ __ ] and i just be out there running
said what is wrong with you man like you
were that kid who just didn't want to
like what's wrong with you so she
started seeing the transformation like
you know this guy is obsessed
with trying to become somebody next
thing she knew man
my god you actually lost that much
weight that fast i love the fact that
you did it but what what hurts me is
when i hear stories about people that
get like stomach stapling and surgery
and all that [ __ ] that they do like you
just need to just lose the weight right
and if you just did it you just did it
the right way you would have earned it
and if you earn it you'll keep it that's
the thing about it man like we like to
take these very quick fixes in life
we want the six minute abs approach to
life yeah nah man there's no permanent
in that yeah there's no permanent in
that man there's no scarring
there must be scarring well people are
terrified of this thing that you're
saying that there's no end
that there's no finish line that every
day is a new thing that you have to earn
it still after all the [ __ ] you've done
every day you get up and you have to
earn it yes you know what's funny about
that
i want you to be scared of it
yeah i want you to just give you fuel
it's great motivation and see if you
look at that way
the reason why
i speak the way i speak because i
believe in what i'm saying
if i ever shut it down
that's the end of me
and whatever my hundred percent will be
i don't know what's gonna happen to me
tomorrow
if you can't run i will figure what the
[ __ ] i can do and do that
that would be my new 100
you must continue to find your new 100
whatever life throws at you you must
find what you can do now
i may become the best you know
scientist of all time who knows watch
out you know what i'm saying
watch out
who knows well that is an approach like
this this approach this mental approach
you can use that for anything once you
get past the quitting mechanism of your
mind once you get past that thing that
this is applicable you can you can take
these lessons that you learn from these
grueling runs yes losing 106 pounds in
three months from all these different
things of struggle you can take these
lessons of struggle and you can apply
them to anything yes i talk about it in
my book here about
that race i did that made seal training
look like a like a child's play in
ranger school that that first hundred
miler i did write [ __ ] on myself and all
kind of stuff
that 19 hours it took me with no
training
i sum it up like this you're talking
about struggle how you can put so much
of life into struggle in that 19 hours
i lived
five years
five years of struggle of happiness of
of depression success failure in 19
hours that's what's great about some of
these things i do you get a a wide range
of life
in just 19 hours
you know like when you get to like mile
50 in your mind saying we gotta get out
of here man and then it gets like miles
60. okay we're feeling good you have all
these highs and lows that you have to
manage within this suck fest of 19 hours
and that's what i get from a lot of
these different things that human growth
you know growth of the mind without
friction there is no growth without
friction there's no growth
there's no growth and there's no
satisfaction
like there's no real like people want to
sit around and rest but you don't really
appreciate rest unless you earned it
that's it and people get they think i'm
the craziest person on the planet you
are so far [ __ ] removed from that
statement it's not even funny i was 290
pounds twice in my life
i do not like to do the things i do but
to humongous satisfaction from doing it
this humongous has facts from lacing
your shoes up saying i don't really want
to go for a run today
and then running
and then getting back and saying wow i
did it i did it yeah and that's what
it's about it's about these small steps
to doing things you don't want to do you
know jocko jocko william i know him yeah
jocko's don't know him great but i know
him i i know him pretty well he's he's
awesome but every morning you look at
that motherfucker's instagram he's got a
picture of his watch at 4 30. he gets up
at 4 30 every morning and he earns a
sunrise that's good stuff it works out
like a [ __ ] and then earns a
sunrise that's good stuff but it's that
thing like there's no end no it doesn't
end and it's scary
that is scary that's scary everybody
wants that holding hands while the sun
sets retirement you're walking off into
the sunset the biggest question i get is
so
when did you rest
when did you recover yeah
and i don't want to scare people
but the truth answer
is i don't take any
days off
no days no days seven days a week seven
days a week what is a normal day normal
day for me a normal day so let's say a
light day light day light day is at
least a seven mile run
i will
every every four every other day so
about four days a week um calisthenics
plus gym workout so i don't do any gym
workout without hitting pull-ups
push-ups i call nickels and dimes so
like five pull-ups ten push-ups or i'll
go you know quarters
and whatever like it's like 25 pull-ups
or in like 50 push-ups so i have all
these different things i messed up so
i will do weights with calisthenics and
every single night i stretch
for at least every night i stretch for
these two hours two hours every
night
every night
so you stretch after you're done working
out yeah so at night time usually i'll
be either in a quiet room or i'll be
watching tv or a good i love sports be
watching the game and i'm on the floor
man and that's what i do
so you just stretch while you're doing
stuff i stretch where i do stuff two
hours a long ass time to stretch is this
just because you're trying to correct
i'm trying to correct um years of not
doing that no years of just do you ever
[ __ ] with yoga a lot yeah yoga is this
[ __ ] what do you do
i have my own yoga
so i kind of invented my own little yoga
for what my body needs i've done hot
yoga several times yoga is huge yoga
shoes like holding those positions and
i'm big and holding them for a long
period of time so that's where my
stretching like people say don't hold
stretches for a long time i hold them
for a long period of time because i'm
trying to get full range of motion a lot
of people going for like like um like my
shoulders all messed up i get surgery on
it nah if you don't have full range of
motion in your body don't go in and get
cut on man until you know that your body
is actually opened up you know we start
to get knuckle dragger syndrome from
doing these push-ups you never work your
back you know like like i'm like i'm
your rear delts
so here you are you start hunching over
before you know your joints are out of
whack you need to get full range of
motion before you know how [ __ ] up you
truly are
so i'm i'm always working on full range
of motion like a kid they run so
effortlessly they're always in full
range of motion
as you get older and tighter and sick
and more stressed your body starts to
get more and more tight therefore your
shoulders start to get out of balance
not a and not a joint not a socket
therefore you know it's popping yeah
it's popping because you're [ __ ]
tight
open it up first open it up can you can
can you touch your hands behind each
other and raise them up behind you you
know it's all these different ranges of
motion that i got real smart on from a
guy and i took it to another level so
are you do you work with a trainer or do
you always work out by yourself
everything i do i've never had training
my entire life really never not one time
do you read about physiology or exercise
science or anything like that nothing
nothing nothing but what about like when
they learn new [ __ ] about new ways to
you know enhance shoulder stability or
new exercises you're not interested no i
don't i don't i don't
i don't do it for that reason
still this day man still this day to
this day
it is for me
to become better mentally
how i look has just become
like i have
thousands thousands hundreds of
thousands of miles on this body running
pull-ups push-ups swimming whatever you
want to call it this body is what it is
now
it's from repetition
it's not from studying you know hey if
you hold your plank for this long [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] i don't i don't care
about it
i just do it for my mind right i want to
continue to harden because that's the
only thing i want
that's what i want
i want to have that mind ready for life
but you also want to increase your range
of motion oh yeah yeah range of motion
make sure that you're you're you know
you're not causing any additional
injuries dude wouldn't you want to like
stabilize some areas that maybe you feel
like you might have weaknesses and find
out new techniques to do that have you
seen me with my shirt off
no yeah it's stable as [ __ ]
i saw you when you had your shirt off
when you first came here i walked in he
dave got here early and uh by the time i
got here he was already doing chin-ups
yeah it's stable
stable do some pull-ups push-up smash
some stable [ __ ] yeah but yeah but you
you know all that stuff is very
important honestly just all jokes aside
man
full range of motion getting your
shoulder rotation all that stuff is very
important i i learned a lot about that
coming up i had a lot of people i worked
out with that that are real smart about
all this stuff
i'm a real old-school meat-eater like
bill casmire type of lifter you know i
don't look like it back when i was that
guy in the back of the skinny guy that
that's what i did and i got off really
big into human performance about the
body strength fitness that's what i
wanted to be i want to be a hybrid
[ __ ] a guy that can run 200
miles and then go to the gym with your
meat head who doesn't even who's scared
of running and lift with him
so that's my whole thing in life i want
to be the guy who can run 200 miles with
the skinny guys
and then go to the gym with the big meat
head and say okay
load it up let's go
so that's my whole thing that's a very
difficult thing to to tie the two of
them together when you think most people
when you think ultra marathon runners or
people that run long distances they're
very thin right very thin guys like when
you were talking about the first time
you ran 100 miles that you did deadlifts
the night before
like that is just [ __ ] preposterous
nobody does that no yeah so me and the
guy talk about the book
it's silverback gorilla is what i call
him in the book that's not his real name
obviously but yeah he saw me go into my
car the night before my first hundred
mile race and you know i was like he
called me out say hey
goggins
come here you know when the navy still
calls you out gotta put you through
three hell weeks you're like you know
what [ __ ]
i gotta go to the gym and lift heavy now
so we're doing squats deadlifts power
cleans heavy bench presses and i'm
thinking
i have to run 100 miles tomorrow but i
also knew he was coming out there to
watch me
so i was like you know what
you put me through three hell weeks you
were my instructor so now it's my turn
to educate you
on what a human can do because i know
you could be sitting there thinking
while you're watching me with your wife
and your kid and you just worked out
with me not before we went real heavy
did the heaviest [ __ ] when we're sore
you're you're gonna sit there while you
watch me run around this one mile track
how the [ __ ] is he doing that [ __ ] right
now
we lifted heavy as hell and he's running
100 miles and never has run past 20
miles in his life
i use that for a lot of fuel so that gym
workout
mr silverback gorilla there was a lot
for my mentality that that brought with
me because i knew i would see you and he
came at mile 50
with a package of six donuts
that i chomped up with the quickness
so yeah so i used that workout for a lot
of motivation i knew he'd see me i know
he'd be thinking about how did you not
get robbed over that day you know what i
don't know what i got that day
but i talked about in the book again
that when i went home that night
or that morning
that was single-handedly nothing even
close i'm 43 years old now there's
nothing even close to that pain i knew
for a fact
i wasn't going to get out of that tub
i knew i i knew i was done
i was talk about dehydrated no nutrition
i was eating rich crackers and my plex
that was the worst pain i'd ever
experienced in my entire life i was
pissing coca-cola out of me it was bad
it was bad she probably did have rob dog
i guarantee it i i guarantee i'm pissing
god cold that's coca-cola no bueno yeah
no brain no son
it was bad and my ex-wife was like
[ __ ] and she's you know she's a nurse
yeah and she called my mom up and mom
had a her friend there was a was was a
doctor friend of hers said hey
you gotta give them to the doctor
immediately and i was like hey you gotta
give me that [ __ ] phone
i gotta call up chris kaufman let him
know i did 100 miles so i get in the bad
water
it didn't go as like you know like i
planned but i did get in the bad water
after another race but um but didn't you
do a marathon like yes later so
basically i had never run a marathon
right i did the 100 mile race first no
training
but i had signed up for the marathon
because it's the first las vegas
marathon running down the strip of las
vegas so las vegas had you know had a
marathon but it's the first time it's
going to go down the strip 2005 like hey
i'm gonna sign up for it i went on to
iraq did you know the deployment and i
come back i'll be training for it and
i'll go do this race with my family me
my ex-wife and my mom signed up for it
so in iraq me and my boy
sledge in the book
we're just working out we're like we're
doing crazy workouts and my cardio was
20 minutes
every sunday on the elliptical trainer
that's the only cardio i did
so i called myself training for this
marathon right so then
you know my my boys got killed in in
that incident that happened long
survivor you know the whole operation
red wings
so that's what prompted me to do the 100
mile race
after the 100 mile race in november it
was like two or three weeks later that
marathon that we all signed up for that
i didn't train for i didn't train for
100 miles didn't doing training off of
this
like hey i'll drive there with you all
because i tried to run the day before
like i can't even run
i can't run down the block so i didn't
do it
so we we're driving to the race i said
hey mom my mom's going to walk it i said
i'm going to walk it with you
my ex-wife i said you can go ahead and
take off do your thing run your race i'm
gonna walk my mom
that gun went off
and something [ __ ] happened
i took
i was like what i took up like a jack
rabbit
gone i was like what the hell so
i re i was thinking the whole time i was
like man i couldn't i spent a hundred
miles like three weeks ago like first
time ever my i was peeing blood and
pissing [ __ ] on myself i go my body's
broken my my achilles and my tendons and
my feet are broken i go what is this
and every time i started running further
in front okay i got to the 10k
i'm on boston marathon time because i
knew the boston marathon was like 3 10
59 for my age i'm like hang on a second
and then i started using all this
external [ __ ] for motivation like okay
who the [ __ ] can go out here and run a
hundred miles no training
like i'm broken most broken i've been in
my life now i'm running a marathon who
could do it so i started just feeding
myself feeding myself i get to half the
mile
i'm about 30 seconds off the pace i say
hang on man your goggins
you can do this [ __ ] man and i started
feeding myself feeding myself feeding
myself you can do this before i knew it
man
i kept talking to like the last six
miles and i was off the pace and i just
kicked it and that next thing i knew i
did like a 308 and change i was like
and that was like what the [ __ ]
what have i been leaving on the table
right i've been leaving so much on the
[ __ ] table
for pain like and that's when i started
like going crazy about the mind like
what the hell am i like what is up
like open these different doors of like
possibility in like what is humanly
possible what are we capable of like you
know people
i didn't even know i was just amazed by
what i was able to do
by a simple fact of just reasoning
and working with pain and pain
management and
in my mind just kept on growing from
there
and it happened in hell week it happened
a hundred mile race happened here it
started just evolving into
what it is now to where now i'm like god
dawg man of mine we are leaving so much
on the table but people take me
he cusses so much she sounds crazy
don't listen all that [ __ ] man just just
cut off the [ __ ]
cut the [ __ ] just get to the weeds
of that you are you are [ __ ] yourself
up by not
examining
your brain
you're not examining your brain message
it that's done
you examine your [ __ ] brain and that
takes some hard work and suffering
if you're not willing to do that i'm
sorry and it seems like there's no way
to do that as a bystander no you can't
watch it man yeah you gotta get out
there like oh this hurts this hurts real
[ __ ] bad
i don't think this is smart
and then guess what happens
the body will adjust
it will adjust anybody goes well then
the next question i get but is there a
time when it doesn't adjust
what the [ __ ]
i get some of the stupidest [ __ ] man
like don't don't take it with a grain of
[ __ ] salt people those questions are
people that are wanting to quit yes yes
and that's what i say when should i quit
yeah like uh did you ever like feel like
no shut the [ __ ] up
stop stop i don't want to like that
there's always that next question
no don't take it like go out there and
run through a brick wall as many times
as you can no i'm not saying be me don't
run 205 miles at one time i'm not saying
do that i'm saying start to learn the
mind is powerful
it's powerful man it's it's unbelievable
but people need they need a thing to get
them going right they need a thing right
they need a goal they need they need a
like it's
sometimes the first step is the hardest
like it's hard to take that one million
step too but sometimes the first step is
the most there's something about the
what do i do
they start going over their phone
they start calling people they don't get
out of the house right
and there's something about
procrastination it's like you know it's
painful you know you should be doing
things but you just keep doing it you
keep itching that scab
[Laughter]
i procrastinate like a [ __ ] man
every day i'm gonna do this [ __ ]
that's what's so funny man people
looking like i'm some damn superhero
that came down from the gods from the
heavens of earth no man
i don't want to do this [ __ ]
i'm looking at my shoes for 30 minutes
sometimes thinking man
[ __ ] man people people look up to you
goggins [ __ ] them i don't wanna do this
i'm like i wanna do this [ __ ] man but
guess what you do it i'm gonna do it as
long as you do it and that's what i know
about it man that's why i stopped doing
i'm thinking oh man you're gonna [ __ ]
sit here you look at your shoes for 30
40 minutes
you go you got to think about it all day
long and you go do it anyway and
sometimes you don't have the time to
look at issues for 30 minutes no those
are the those are the beautiful days yes
because you know you just have to go
that's right and so like there's no room
for procrastination and that's when i
was in the military i love my schedule
because i knew how to work at seven
o'clock so you better get your ass up at
four o'clock man you get your [ __ ] in
brother cause i had to get my [ __ ] in
before i got my [ __ ] in right you know
so that was my mentality back then man
you know like i i had to
get the miles and get everything in man
and
and get to work man i'm uh competing
with the alpha males yeah but how much
did that piss other alpha males off that
you were you were imposing a very high
bar i
i was a very misunderstood human being
when i was in the military the air force
guys liked me a lot the rangers liked me
a lot
so much not the seals because they were
with you they they didn't like me so
much which is fine you know i i respect
them i think a lot of them respect i've
have a lot of friends in the seal teams
a lot of guys that like like-minded
mentalities as me
and once again i grew up and i got over
it a lot of guys still have you know
like a lot of people can't get over the
fact of whatever when i became a seal
recruiter
a lot of guys thought i wasn't deploying
for a lot of reasons and whatnot and
they
i heard a lot i was that guy who grinded
i grinded hard
i mean i i grounded hard i was that guy
who was up like if we went on an op or
we had a
work up let's say we had a work up we're
an island we're out there shooting guns
and and doing land warfare and we did it
like one o'clock in the [ __ ] morning
most everybody go to sleep
i didn't go to sleep i went to the gym
and i worked out
or i'd go sleep and i said we'd be up at
five o'clock i was up at four o'clock
and got my hour in
i made sure to always do that
and i i did it to a point to where i
think it pissed some people off because
i i want a quiet person about it
you know i i uh
i want the most humble person always
you know so when you're around alpha
males
um you're sometimes picking a fight
you know all the time and i looked
different i acted different i was
different i am different i take a lot of
pride in that
and so you know if if you didn't get
after it i didn't respect you
because i believe that you know where
where i'm at
i i know that human potential is what we
have it's all we have is what we the the
world sees us a certain way
and when i saw that people weren't doing
that i had a funky ass [ __ ] attitude
and i i own it in my book i come back
from ranger school a big time leader i
was a big time [ __ ] leader i got
honor man out there i live by example
and what i realized a lot of times when
you're in these schools
these schools people want to graduate
these schools because they suck they
don't want to ever go back to these
schools
those schools became my [ __ ] life
people don't want to see a [ __ ] god
that wants to go back to day one week
one a [ __ ] navy still training every
[ __ ] day of your life and that's how
i live
and it's a disgusting human being that i
can be
it is and a lot of people didn't like me
a lot of [ __ ] people started some
stupid [ __ ] and started saying this and
that the bottom line man is my [ __ ]
resume says it all man
my resume is out there google the
[ __ ] you say whatever you want
to say about me man
i i i miss some deployments man for
having [ __ ] you know two heart
surgeries and
people trying to start some rumors [ __ ]
on me man you started rumors [ __ ] on me
man because i [ __ ] got the [ __ ] after
it and real hard guys
like a guy named hawk i talked to all
the time
yeah
he's a great friend of mine when the
hardest my first
before my heart surgery my second heart
surgery i went on a 10 mile wreck around
before my second heart rate the day of
it
i went on a 10 mile work on 50 pounds
i saw that guy he's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing out here he got heart
surgeon it's roger that brother
i'm getting it in before i'll be out for
about six months after the heart surgery
that was my mentality because i started
realizing at a young age
when i was leaving on the table
and once i found out what a human
being's capable of
i didn't know how to control that
i was i was a [ __ ] talk about [ __ ]
savage
that's what i was i was a [ __ ]
straight up people talk about savage
very lightly
i was [ __ ] from the back woods
[ __ ] savage dude you know and
and i just i was just i was
i told you what i thought i i had eight
chips on my shoulder
i um
and a lot of times that wasn't great so
is it a situation where like with the
seals where once you've gotten through
buds and once you've gotten through all
the physically grueling parts of
getting to be accepted once you're in
then you were imposing standards that
they didn't want to
they didn't want to keep up with i i
would say some people you know i i had
uh i had one platoon that i had a
problem with you know like i like i i i
graduated ranger school and i got in
this platoon and i didn't see i don't
know i was in charge of a pt program
and you put me in charge of the pt
program it's [ __ ] your ass
and the thing about it i didn't like it
either i didn't i didn't want to do this
[ __ ] either man but what were you making
them do like you know like i it was it
was some maybe it was some bud [ __ ] you
know we went back to buzz like you know
long peak tees and carrying logs over
the berms and [ __ ] and like i had us do
like pull-ups rope climbs pull up like
for like a [ __ ] hour so imagine doing
a rope climb then go do like 10 to 15
pull-ups coming back
and we would do like these they were
very hard workouts like there was no
like go to the gym lift some weights
type of [ __ ]
and i was imposing
my own mentality on everybody these are
grown ass [ __ ] men they know you know
they don't want to be what i'm trying to
make them to be
and when they called me off
like hey you know we're not in sealed
you know we're not in buds anymore
goggins it pissed me off
and i uh and i got a little [ __ ]
attitude got my chip and i got my ball
and
me me and sledge went ahead and started
to work out together
and we developed this like me and sleds
work out like [ __ ] girl animals and
we had this [ __ ] mentality of [ __ ]
yeah we're getting answered every day
and everybody's kind of did their own
thing man
and i just that's when i started looking
at people you know not just but people
very differently man cause i bit into
like
you know like to be the special operator
you gotta be have broken legs and these
guys all those stories i was the same
guy man i i put people on a pedestal
i put people like i could never be them
i could never be that guy man never put
anybody on a pedestal that's what
happened to me i put him on a pedestal
once i got up there with him and i saw
him and once again not everybody some
hard [ __ ] out there dude period
dot hard [ __ ]
i thought every [ __ ] was hard
hey
hey
uncommon amongst uncommon men
that's all it was about for me man and i
took it to another level and i pissed a
lot of [ __ ] off
and they were trying to find chinks in
my armor then they were they were trying
to find chinks in the armor
you know all he does is run
all he does is [ __ ] run
that's why you know but once again i
don't talk about the military too much
like i said the air force loved me
the army guys i work with love me the
ranger school all that stuff love me you
know i wasn't you know it's just what it
is man it's uh i was part of the navy
seals
i was a i was a team guy
but i wasn't part of the brotherhood
and that's just me man that's just me it
ain't saying nothing bad about them i
got a lot of love for a lot of them
love them a lot ain't got love for me
but i'm gonna talk bad about them it's
just i'm different that's something i
figured out i'm different from everybody
in the [ __ ] world
and i had to own that and say you know
what man you made a lot of [ __ ]
mistakes being it's uh
being who you are
and i should have been more of a leader
at times but a lot of times a lot of
people should have been a little bit
harder too
so was it that some of those guys just
didn't want to work as hard or was it
just that they were they weren't
appreciating how competitive you were
you were always against them is that
what it was that it didn't foster the
sense of brotherhood because you were
more like come on [ __ ]
i i i didn't really call them [ __ ]
but you could look at my face and how i
looked at you
and you know you can you can kind of say
this you know so what happens i started
developing this like this separation
another thing about me too man i don't
go out
i don't party i don't hang out with the
guys i don't you know so
i was always forming this kind of
separation i'm a big time introvert you
know i do my job
and i don't want to see your [ __ ] ass
again i'm gonna go home refresh and
we'll see you again you know you're in a
platoon with these guys for two two
years sometimes year and a half
and i would you know we work up do our
[ __ ] and i i'm just i'm just a different
[ __ ] cat i'm a different cat man like
i uh
you know i just i i think differently i
i believe differently
um
and i i believe strongly what i believe
in well some people must appreciate the
fact that you were self-motivated and
that you were pushing the envelope that
you were pushing the pace you were
setting a high bar yeah i have a lot of
guys right now within the community a
lot of a lot of guys once again this is
like
it's like a big soap opera sometimes man
when you know when we when you're in a
fraternity like that that's what it's
like man so i had to get a different
vantage point look at it and see like
you know a lot of guys did respect who i
was and what i did
and um i i brought it [ __ ] hard a lot
and every day
but i also rub people the wrong way
i'm like that itch you're talking about
i'm like that itch
you want to scratch the [ __ ] out my ass
no sir
you wanna just like [ __ ] this dude man
i love what you talked about
when you ran the marathon you realize
how much you were leaving on the table
because that is um
i mean i think
the the unfulfilled potential is the
story of most people's lives
it is
it is it and it could have been the
story of mine
and i tell a lot of people people go
what's your biggest fear in life
and my biggest fear honestly was
let's say this let's say uh i don't care
if you believe in god or not i don't
care so this let's just play a game with
me let's say let's say you're god
and we have a big [ __ ] long line of
people and i made to heaven 75 years old
i'm 300 pounds i made heaven i worked
for ecolab my entire life praying for
cockroaches that's what i did
but i'm dead i'm in heaven now and you
are at you're you're judging us all now
so we're in line we're all sitting there
in line
you have
adam brown
he has a big board up and you're talking
to adam brown about his life
and you rip it down and i'm next in line
david goggins
i see my name and i see all this [ __ ]
and god goes hey you say read this man
and i'm reading this list and i'm seeing
182 pounds
navy seal ranger school
motivational speaker changing lives
okay man pull up record all this [ __ ]
and i'm like
that's not me man
and god looks at me and says that's who
you were supposed to be
and my biggest fear i i visualize some
crazy [ __ ] my biggest fear is that one
day i want to reach a judgment of my
life
someone something is going to judge me
what the [ __ ] i was supposed to be in
life
and
what i want now is that whoever's
judging me whatever judge me up there
i want them to have a board
and them up there right now
getting their pin out
because you know this person who judges
supposed to know everything supposed to
know from the time you're dead the time
you're you know you know time you're
born time you're dead i want this person
up there to be like this up there
writing more about me saying [ __ ] i know
i know you could do that i i know you
can do that so i want to impress
whatever the [ __ ] is up there whatever's
going on in life i want to go up there
and not have anything left on the table
i want to i want to drain my soul of
every [ __ ] bit
of person i am now how do you plan on
doing that but going forward in the
future do you have a plan yeah so what i
did i i believe in going back to scratch
so a lot of us like right now i've i've
come a long way in my life i've had to
grow up a lot except a lot of the
[ __ ] things i've done in my life i'd
accept a lot i took all this information
big database took it all
so what got me to be where i'm at today
is data
i collect even more data now which way i
can write this book which i can tell
people hey
you know i [ __ ] have a lot of faults
i have a mentality that can sometimes
rub people all this [ __ ]
so how you get better is so right now
i'm way up here now i was way down here
but what makes you way up here is
being from way down here so i love going
back i called so when i was growing up
for like three years
so from time i was eight to time i was
like 12
we live in a seven dollar a month place
and what i call it is i'm always paying
rent
in that seven dollar a month home
every day of my life i go back and
revisit that place because that place
made me
this geranimal that place made me this
hard man and then from that place so
that that place is hard work
that place is going back to the
fundamentals of life the fundamentals
what made david gaga's david goggins
going back in there going back to the
going back to the library of david
goggins studying even more than what i
know taking that out going back to where
i'm at now and then moving forward
so i believe in always taking steps
backwards to to your roots we we cannot
forget the roots and what made us the
geranimal we can never become civilized
isn't it granite that like little kids
clothes it's a little kid's clothes but
i love the word
i love his clothes or drinks
i don't know his clothes or drinks man
but something like that
so
when when you when you're living like
right now like what kind of goals are
you setting and how how are you how are
you how are you feeding that beast
inside of you how are you calming all
that down
stretching helped a lot you know so when
you wire yourself up so much yoga
yoga and stretching has really helped me
to like
you want to be quiet in your mind
to see where you want to go because
noise
is the ultimate kryptonite
too much noise in your mind you're not
going to be focused on what the task at
hand is it's one of the things that i
found like long cardio so the best thing
ever for calming that noise yes we all
talked about that all the guys that i
did that sober october thing with the
fitness challenge that like if you work
out five hours a day you don't give a
[ __ ] no it's it's amazing i'm like if
you could take that and put it in a pill
form how you feel about life after you
work out five hours yep you don't give a
[ __ ] nothing bothers you like nothing
you
nothing because you've struggled true my
fiancee right now it's like hey i got
xyz i'm like i'll take you she's like
what you won't look at shoes i'll take
you like what i'm like i just worked out
for four hours man
i [ __ ] sit down this [ __ ]
chair all day long son yeah yeah i'm
chill it's different yeah i i get all
that [ __ ] out i ring the rag out in the
morning time and whatever you want to do
i'm here man most people never get there
though no they always have that chatter
always it was negative anger the guy who
cut you off yesterday oh yeah all day
still on your head yep all day long man
chatter challenge
maybe i should do this maybe i should
have done that i should never let that
guy get away with that exactly i should
have done this i should have taken that
job oh i should have moved i should have
stuck with her
all that
that was me man yeah that was my people
yeah why don't people like me
amazing that that long cardio just calms
that chatter like that though yes like i
i never uh until october i've never
really done long cardio every day it
beats that testosterone up man beats
everything up yeah that test you're like
[ __ ] done yeah you're cool yeah
you're cool man it's not just that it's
like it's i always talk about people's
brains that i think that the the way
people's minds work that we're like a
battery that's like leaking out it's
like since we don't use it because we
have all this potential we don't use it
like it oozes off the top of the batter
and it gets messy right it's going down
the sides of the battery it's all [ __ ]
up but when you just drain that [ __ ]
like nature intended like give you the
potential to run away from predators
avoid invading tribes and to fight and
gather and hunt and all the physical
potential that your body is capable of
when you do drain it with like a 10 mile
run or right long cardio session long
workout session
then you can just be you it's the great
purge man the purge it's the purge you
purge all that [ __ ] demon [ __ ] out
man all the evil
evil can't stay in a 10 mile run bro
it's going to get leaked right the [ __ ]
out it does it gets pounded out pound it
out yeah but you could see things clean
more clearly and that is only available
through effort i mean maybe it's
available through meditation i don't
know but i feel like there's a different
thing that's available through effort
because there's also a satisfaction of
accomplishment oh yeah effort's huge man
it means everything
because you gotta feel good about
yourself now what do you do you plan out
your future
i do so i'm very go so i have that
accountability mirror but i also plan on
all my small big time you know medium
goals all these things i have to do in
life
i'm a big planner
i'm a big planner
so you know right now i'm going back to
scratch so i'm trying to be wildland
firefighter you know i did that for a
couple seasons you're gonna do that now
yeah so i did it for i did it for two
not not full season but but two half
seasons so this year was my second year
doing it i had to i had to um stop about
two months before it ended because of
this book
to start promoting the book and start
finishing the book up but i've been
doing the opportunity that's some
[ __ ] work man
those [ __ ] guys get after what made
you decide to do that
the work you know like when your hands
stop becoming really calloused
it's time to get back to work
you know like i retired from the
military i did 21 years in the military
um the military was my life loved
everything about it the discipline of it
um there's something about going back in
the in the money you make is nil it's
not about the money at all
it's just about the hard work i've
always been looking for those people
like those guys like you're out there
digging
a three mile fire line
literally a three mile fire line you're
cutting down these [ __ ] huge ass
trees to dig this fire line
and the fire line is like 20 to 18
inches
for three miles and you get like [ __ ]
12 people digging this [ __ ]
and i'm thinking man this is some of the
hardest [ __ ] work i've done in my
life and it's that challenge that you
can't find sometimes by going to the gym
or by running you know 100 mile race is
that it's that new challenge of like hey
and you get done digging
all right
you work 17 hours 16 17 hours
you get your [ __ ] little [ __ ]
sleeping mat out shack down boom right
there on the floor right there on the
ground get up dig some more
you know be out there two three weeks
sometimes man it's doing that [ __ ] and
there's great satisfaction in the kind
of work that you do out there
no one's watching no one gives a [ __ ]
it's hard dangerous [ __ ] work
and you know you're doing it to help
[ __ ] out man you know how did you get
drawn into that
so i got drawn into it because i was
always looking for the next challenge
and i was like hey what is there after
the military
like what the [ __ ] is there man i'm i'm
43
um i'm getting back in shape you know
i'm [ __ ] getting these health issues
taken care of that i had and
i started once again google is amazing
[ __ ]
hardcore [ __ ] jobs you know pretty
much you know hard-ass [ __ ] you know
that's i found the horse you know like
the first race you know hardest races in
the world
so
basically i started finding this
wildland fire fight like what the [ __ ]
is wildland firefight started googling
that started googling smoke jumpers you
know i'm like what the [ __ ] these guys
do
what they jump out of planes and attack
small fires like that's the [ __ ] so i'm
like okay okay we could put down a list
and okay hot shots what's the hot shot
dude
they go out with you know big fires and
they dig fire line they i'm like [ __ ]
with nick from that and i saw a video of
it like that [ __ ] looks like it sucks
it's hot you know there's lim you know i
mean you're out there on your own i mean
you know you're out there on your own
man just digging a fire line so that's
kind of how i found it i'm always
looking for the next challenge
i'm never satisfied with oh
i did that like you know i became a seal
i was an air force guy i became a seal i
went to ranger school i tried out for
delta force twice
you know like i'm always looking for
what is next looking for those uncommon
men
and women uncommon people because i'm
trying to i'm trying to grow
i'm trying to grow
and a lot of times you know you don't be
the only person that's making yourself
grow you're looking for those cameron
haynes those joe rogan those people who
are like just different
people who understand what the [ __ ]
they're saying because a lot of things i
have to say
i can't say them all
i can't say them all you may not
understand them so i had to really find
a way to communicate with people so they
don't think oh my god like what what did
you just say
so these cameron haynes is these joe
work these people get it so i go in
those little those little nucleus spots
get get a little more strength get a
little more knowledge get a little more
tools
take those tools with me put in my tool
shed
and i go off down you know down the road
on a new journey
so that's what i do
well the proof is in the pudding if
you're really doing woodland
firefighting because there's no glory in
that no sir no there's no fame there's
no there's no one taking pictures of you
no and that paycheck is small son
i'mma [ __ ] make you wanna
should i eat today yeah wow yeah there's
there's nothing involved in that man
they worked their ass off so but you're
just doing it as a challenge that's it
did they freak out when you're there you
know what i i think they're wondering
why is a 43 year old retired man
you know
all the stuff you've done why are you
out here yeah and i explain it to them
i'm out here i'm out here you know to to
learn from you all to grow
and also to never forget where i came
from
you know
that's where it starts
it's that mentality of i'm gonna pick up
that [ __ ] pulaski and i'm gonna dig
this [ __ ] fire line for three damn
miles
that's that mentality i never want to
lose i never want to get so nice oh yeah
i did it man
i did it
i did it i'm good
that mentality of i'm willing to pick up
that shovel and i'm willing to dig a
three-mile line
is th there's something about that
mentality that i'm ready to go to work
at any time and that's what keeps me
those are the sparks like you know i
look at
motivation as just a spark it's like
it's like kindling you know how how a
big fire starts it starts with a little
smoke it starts with a little cigarette
being thrown in the woods next thing all
californians [ __ ] burn up
that's what i've been doing my whole
life is i find these little sparks
and once that little thing takes off
that's a that's a one hour fuel then
you've got 10 hour fuel
then you can move that thing to a 10 000
hour fuel
these big logs and big trees that burn
for days and that's where you want to
bring that motivation that's where you
want to bring that drive so if you have
no kingling the kindling is me going out
with these young guys saying all right
[ __ ] you're 43. it's a 20 year
old keep up with them
that kindling now when i leave those
young guys it has now become that ten
hour fuel and now that ten thousand
dollar fuel that i use throughout my
whole life
i use that there my whole life man hey
this summer at 43 you went out there and
you did that man so you know you're not
giving up yet you're not done yet not
today you're not done today that's a
crazy choice to make though woodland
firefighter is a very interesting choice
it is
it is it's a nasty job man because again
that's
that's proof of concept
like you're really just doing just for
the struggle that's it is there other
things you considered like that
um so i will i apply for smoke jumping
this year
so i'll be out smoke jumping this year
you know god willing
um
that's where it's at now that that right
now is my next military
that's my next military
and that's it's always about human
growth it's not about money it's not
about money human growth that's the
biggest like i said my biggest trophy
that's why i turn down 300 thousand
dollars
the biggest trophy in life is what i've
learned like this brain if i could put
this brain in somebody's head and say
here you go merry christmas
they'd be a happy person what i found
out is that with no crowds
no one cheering for you
no races no finish line
it's an amazing amazing thing i've
learned in my mind by no one cheering
you on like
like what that is is every morning i do
what i do
i don't have a trainer waking me up
there's no one saying david you have to
do this
i don't have to do anything anymore i've
done it
that's the beauty of all this knowing
that everything i talk about no one even
knows what the [ __ ] i'm doing every day
and i know that i am grinding like a
[ __ ] they see a one minute video
let me run in or some [ __ ] hopefully
it motivates you merry christmas
dude
i'm out there for [ __ ] hours every
[ __ ] day and no one sees what the
[ __ ] i'm doing
no one it's a great beautiful thing man
that is a beautiful thing about it right
that you really are just doing it for
the benefits of it that's it that you
have to do it that way it's not for show
like there's a lot of people like you'll
see like they have a little video they
do on instagram like [ __ ] you are not
doing that for very long you're going
too fast that's it that's it this is not
real i got my one minute on yeah
take now yeah
yeah yeah exactly this is so much a
visit for show
i do enjoy those videos that you're
doing on instagram though we appreciate
these little motivational things i put
some of them up on my page i appreciate
it we posted it there's a those are
those are great man like would you are
you just like do you just get a thought
in your head while you're out there
running you just want to get it down
yeah so what i'll do is i my fiance does
all these videos man so god bless you
it's sometimes it'll be three o'clock in
the [ __ ] morning
and i'll be working out and i said hey
wake the [ __ ] up i got some [ __ ] and
she's like what like hey man it came to
me man i got some [ __ ] for these people
man so that's what happens like usually
when i'm working out
i get this great inspiration
i
some people might think it's [ __ ]
but
my my mind works best
under extreme pain and suffering like oh
my god i want to be out here and that's
when i'm going deep into the cellar of
my mind and that's when all that
gargoyle [ __ ] starts to come up man you
know what i'm saying
and so
she gets called out all the time like
hey
i'll run home and say hey get the car
meet me at 17th street because by that
time i have all my [ __ ] together so
that's how this happens man it's not
like a rehearse thing that's why
sometimes i may post on monday usually
it's like every monday but sometimes
it's tuesday sometimes it's thursday
you know i and that's what i do i i'm
trying to now give back to people
in a way that's real and authentic and
just being me what is the response been
like like after you did the podcast the
first time what was the response like
and what is the response like on social
media what was crazy man is that you are
my usher and i'm [ __ ] bieber that's
the [ __ ] response man
so your crowd um for some reason they
they resonate with me they they
understand they they they get me
and they they love the message
and
like so if you put some [ __ ] up on
my site i i block and delete your ass
this ain't this ain't a playground like
like my site i'm not [ __ ] around with
you [ __ ] i want to give you
some tools that i learned if you want to
take them take them if not merry
christmas i'll go on my merry way i
don't care so if you go on there you
want to play around and you want to you
know whether they called um those people
going inside troll [ __ ] ain't trying
my [ __ ] i'm going gonna block your
monkey ass off my [ __ ] quick
i want so i i've been friends jamie yeah
tell them so i've developed like a small
community of people who can go in there
and it's not just me talking so people
have now joined in and they're i've seen
people lose 150 pounds on my site man
like and they're writing about and
they're starting to break themselves
down like i broke myself down they're
like hey i went through this i went
through this divorce and this happened
and i tried to kill myself it gets raw
and then people are now
going on and commenting on their [ __ ]
saying hey keep it up do what you're
doing it's become like a big [ __ ]
like hey
it's a community of people trying to
[ __ ] get better and that's what it's
about man this ain't about the david
goggins [ __ ] show
no man i'm mr kingly
you [ __ ] take this [ __ ] and let
the [ __ ] burn
also you probably need all these other
people out there grinding two for fuel
oh man i want to know that's the thing
now like people go what motivates you
now
what motivation now is that there's over
600 some odd thousand people
looking at me saying
[ __ ] goggins is somewhere out
there
he's somewhere out there [ __ ] getting
after it and i am so you ain't never
[ __ ] alone
i'm out there somewhere
600 some thousand people there's a
chance that when you're working out i
don't care if you're in [ __ ]
washington dc and i'm in nashville
there's a good chance at the same time
we're getting after it and i want people
to know that and it's the real deal we
are getting after it together not no
like happy family [ __ ] but we're getting
after it
you know yeah well that is that's giant
for people man that the sense of
community and to know that there's
like-minded folks out there that are
also trying to improve they're trying to
overcome their own demons get past their
own [ __ ] and squash their own
weaknesses callous up their own mind i
love that
you know it's not time for some soft
[ __ ] it's not time for soft [ __ ] man
this isn't a [ __ ] playground don't
come on my instagram facebook or twitter
talking some [ __ ]
come on if you want to if you want to
join the community and get hard
and see what you're about don't talk
about rest you know how do you do it no
let's [ __ ] stop thinking so much and
let's put the shoes on and get grinding
you do get some of that though there's
some comments that say you know this is
terrible advice rest and recovery is the
most important thing god
you ain't all my [ __ ] son
you're not gonna last no my sight yeah i
wanna hear that [ __ ] there's a lot of
people looking for built-in excuses they
are man they are
they're looking for it but then there's
a lot of people also that are just
really interested in
personal growth they're they're
interested in really finding out what
they're made of they're interested in
improving their ability to toughen up
and discipline themselves and they're
looking they're looking for people like
you and other people just add to that
momentum right once you get going it's
easier to keep going that's it man once
you get going it's easier to keep
showing up it is it is you have to get
past that hurdle yeah and once you get
past it man you're flying and then you
see other people that are doing it too
and you realize like this is a this is a
movement there's a lot of other people
out there it is a movement yeah it is a
movement well that's the thing that
resonates with you i think about the
audience of this podcast that i've had
quite a few people on that have that
same message and it resonates with
people because we're all trying to
improve ourselves no one's perfect nope
there's no i'm not perfect now i never
will be you're not and you never will be
but you're better than you were
yesterday and you're gonna be better
tomorrow that's the truth thing right
there man that's that book says i am not
[ __ ] perfect man i had the balls to
now finally tell you all i am very
flawed but in that saying that you're
very flawed and saying that you're very
perfect you exhibit way more strength
than someone who bullshits and pretends
right someone who puts up some fake ass
[ __ ]
fake facade of perfection right of moral
integrity and growth and honesty and
those people are a real problem because
it's exhausting
how the [ __ ]
i did it for a while i'm like i can't
hey i'm [ __ ] up
i give up i quit i quit i quit i'm
[ __ ] up i'm gonna tell you all i can't
do this anymore this is who i am but the
confidence of you of constantly grinding
and constantly putting in that work is
what leads you to be able to express
yourself so honestly oh you're right i i
for the first time believe in david
goggins and i don't care who else
believes in me i don't care for the
first time in my life man i can tell you
all my [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and without lying that's powerful no
longer care
that's powerful that see everybody could
get to that then you do you don't have
any excuses because you don't need any
that's right you don't need anything
none you don't like me merry christmas
[ __ ]
kwanzaa keep moving that's it go yeah
that's it good luck to you okay
exactly yeah we're all in this thing
together
yeah you got your own path you didn't
want us to stare at those shoes for 30
minutes
every day
that's so true man that's so true
so fire jumping and woodland
firefighting i didn't expect that i
didn't hear that coming yeah that's
interesting man yep and what did you
have any other options that you were
looking at before you dived into those
you know what those are the first that
came up because i saw how hard it was
you know like at 43 in these jobs like
like in the military you're a dinosaur
time to retire and while in firefighting
you know you start to move into these
desk jobs and that was the challenge of
it you know i'm like i'm like a [ __ ]
rookie at 43. right so i'm like being
talked like a little [ __ ] so it takes a
lot for me you know i'm like yeah i've
done some things man hang on now but i
have to now humble myself again right
it's hard to humble yourself you got
some 21 year old little punk ass [ __ ]
saying hey
pick up that [ __ ] and come on i'm like
what what the [ __ ] you say i'm like you
know but i'm like okay god it's like
you're rookie man like so that's all the
training behind the mindset of it all
right is that
you can't ever be the point you never
learn from people right you know you
have to always humble yourself and go
back to that yeah you know like right
now there's people listening this
podcast like oh yeah you're great guys
no you ain't [ __ ] goggins
and that's the mindset i always want to
have not like i'm not proud of myself
but you have to always keep that like i
want to keep that dog in me
and i can't always know everything yeah
well being a beginner at something is
fantastic it's amazing being learning
new things is fantastic for everything
else so much growth in that have you do
you [ __ ] around with martial arts
you know what
i learned a little bit
i've i've never gone crazy in it i've
never gone crazy i boxed a little bit
where do you live i live in nashville
there's a lot of jiu jitsu in nashville
you should get involved in jiu jitsu you
would take like a duck to water i'll
find you a spot
yeah hook me up i'll find you a spot you
would you get obsessed with that [ __ ] oh
god is that so yeah that's a
never-ending pile of [ __ ] tangled
bodies and strangled people here we go
because it's something that you just get
better at all the time and there's no
hiding right either you get choked or
you don't either you survive or you
don't now i've been on a lot of ground
i've been a lot of ground games man but
i've never really learned the skill sets
yeah so it'd be nice to do that i'll
hook it up yeah please do i think you
would get obsessed with it the same way
jack was obsessed with it same with a
lot of other
seals get obsessed with martial arts it
would be nice to do it because it's also
constant competition as well i mean you
can get into competition every single
night of the week really and yeah
absolutely and as a a guy who's just
starting out you're going to be a white
belt you're going to get strangled a lot
you want to choke the [ __ ] out
from the beginning you're going to start
from the beginning 100
there's plenty of guys your size there's
plenty of guys that
have been doing it for [ __ ] decades i
know a lot of guys like to get their
hands on me so i'll be good yeah oh
goggins you're coming huh okay
okay but it's also a good thing to have
the kind of cardio and endurance you
have too
yeah that's where i get people so i've
i've rolled with a lot of guys who have
skills
but the thing that i really have and i'm
not gonna brag on it man is i got a
[ __ ] up cardio bass man
i got a [ __ ] up cardio bass man and my
mentality is kind of [ __ ] up too yeah
so i realized that we're fighting that
if you get a big cardio base and your
mindset's [ __ ] up too
cardio is almost everything
skills skills are everything because a
lot of guys with skills also have some
cardio they have enough to [ __ ] you up
right but to have tremendous cardio
with big skills is everything i see him
out there man dying yeah because so many
guys started 100
but three minutes into the fight they're
at 80. right you know five minutes into
the fight they're at 60. that's right
and then they recover for a minute they
come back but if you're if you are in
like a rolling session like when you
roll you roll for nine minutes straight
so you and this guy and you there's most
of the time there's multiple taps right
you'll tap him he'll tap you you tap
each other but nine minutes man it is
exhausting when that bell goes off the
last you know the the the bell for 30
seconds and you got 30 seconds left in
nine minutes and then dinging it's over
you're like
you're done and then you take a minute
off you find a new partner that's good
[ __ ] get back in there you'd love it it
sounds like a good grind yeah that's the
next grind right there you love it yeah
you blacked out hey so long that take
about if i went like this hard at it
it's hard to say because uh it depends
entirely upon how much emphasis you put
on learning new techniques and rolling
and drilling drilling is gigantic and
that's the thing that people don't like
to do because jiu-jitsu is so fun people
like to just roll right because it's
sparring is where it's at like i don't
want to do all those practice i want to
choke people right like i knew a few
things like do that okay and then i do
this
okay let me get in there now you want
it's like a lot of uh jiu jitsu schools
they'll start out with like one or two
techniques and then you roll most of the
class is just sparring right but the
right way to do it really is to drill
way more than you spar okay you should
be drilling all the time and live
drilling too like you start out where a
guy has your back ready go and then from
there you got to try to escape and do it
the right thing to try to use the right
technique to get out of that position or
you'll start out
uh with an arm bar but he's defending
and you've got to figure out how to
extend it you know and those live drills
straight drills like technique drills
and then live drills are i think even
more important in the beginning
to uh to to your personal development
and growth as a jiu jitsu player than
even sparring but a guy like you who's
smart and tough and will go crazy
[ __ ]
it shouldn't take that long
it takes people i mean it depends on how
much you dedicate yourself to it right
right b.j penn got his black belt in
three years what yeah but it's crazy
he's bj penn he's up like
the prodigy for a reason right
right i had a conversation with him
about it though it was really
interesting once
he uh he goes uh he was talking to some
other dude and the guy said uh i got my
uh black belt at three years just like
you did bj and he's like wow man he goes
you must be good he goes no man he goes
i'm addicted just like you he goes you
were addicted you're addicted and he's
like i never thought about it that way
he goes yeah i'm addicted to jiu jitsu
it's like you're addicted like it takes
over your mind right it's everything
your days are spent thinking about some
guy who triangled you this [ __ ]
how do you get me [ __ ]
like i get that dude i got choked out
ten years ago that i think about
sometimes when i'm lifting i'll be tired
and i'll think about a guy who caught me
ten years i'm not like [ __ ] yeah just
that's what's great about life man is i
think about not being choked out by
thinking about a lot of [ __ ] like that
yeah little failures just keep you
pushing they grind on me like a
[ __ ] man and that's what you're
talking about earlier too it's like the
the the mind has these reserves you can
trick it and pull them out yes these
inspirational reserves like you did
when when you when you guys were going
through buds yes we just found that
trigger and then all of a sudden you
throw in that boat in the air the mind
always has the tactical advantage over
you
why is that
it knows your fears it knows your
insecurities it knows where they're
hiding you can't hide can't hide from
that [ __ ] man
that [ __ ] has a tactical
advantage on you son that's gonna get
you man
it's a beast that might be your best
lesson right that your mind your mind
knows everything you cannot hide from it
so don't ever try don't try you might as
well go ahead and beat that [ __ ]
gotta keep going at it that's also what
you did in this book you didn't try to
like
paint yourself in a glamorous or
flattering way at any point in time you
were honest at every step of the way
which i think is just gigantic for
people too because
you can tell when someone's stroking
themselves or bullshitting themselves
and the message just won't come through
right but this you're you come through
in this book you know like you who you
are and what you became and how you
became who you are and who you used to
be and why you were the way you used to
be all that comes through it's like
there's no filter this is just your your
thoughts like you what you remember
about your life and what you think about
right now just all comes out onto the
pages hardest thing i've done my entire
life
i'm imagining i have [ __ ] i don't
know how people buy this book
then i walk up to people people walk up
to me i'm like what are you thinking
about [ __ ]
hey thinking about me peeing in the bed
you [ __ ]
what are you thinking about oh
that's hilarious i know right like you
like are you thinking about me opening
it up yeah you know all about me hey how
about you [ __ ]
tell me something about you
that's what people love right when they
know some [ __ ] about you you don't know
nothing about them i don't know about
nobody that's anonymous trolls that's it
man and they get at me they come oh
there's a lot of those
but that they're all doing that to
themselves they don't even understand
when you do that you're doing it to
yourself right if you are attacking
someone because you know that they have
a weakness but you're pretending you
don't have one you are attacking
yourself you are chipping away your own
personal sovereignty
chipping away at your own respect so
true man can't respect yourself you know
you're a [ __ ] but that's what happened
though joe to me i started looking at
people realizing
i know something about you
because they don't want to talk about it
right i already know it yeah if you're
talking [ __ ] about me yeah
i know you're [ __ ] up yeah that's what
all these cats that come out right now
who don't like me whatever i'm like
really man that [ __ ] happened 30 [ __ ]
years ago 15 years ago you still you're
still [ __ ] up about that
oh man i know something about you
brother see i get over everything i'm
good
it's it's water under the [ __ ] bridge
it's a grind it's the the grind does
that that's it
you're not grinding harder if if you're
worried about something that someone did
to you years ago
you're being a [ __ ] to yourself man not
getting out there and squeezing that
[ __ ] soul out every day yeah if you
grind hard man i got time to worry about
your monkey ass
i i got to tell me about you man because
tomorrow
i gotta go back to the grind
and tomorrow i go back to the grind
again and again and again and again i
don't have time to put you into the hate
bank there's no hate it's all filtered
out man through the grind people don't
get it there's there's great joy in the
grind the great jordan to suffer it
totally cleanses your body out man of
any kind of hate makes you grow up
it's also the being honest about it
every step of the way the way you are in
this book and the way you are the way
you talk about things you're not not
trying to paint yourself in a flattering
way no it it forces you to continue to
perform right by exposing all the [ __ ]
that you used to do by exposing your
procrastination your your slips your f
your fallings you're falling back down
and getting fat again all that stuff it
forces you to be consistent like you
know you did it today you know you did
it today do you know you're going to be
able to do it tomorrow well you have to
you have to know that you have to know
and that's my biggest fear man is that i
know
i can slip
everybody goes man
you're not permanent
[ __ ]
no one's permanent almost [ __ ]
permanent that's why people that have
accomplished great things and then want
to talk about those great things to the
end of time and not do anything anymore
no they're [ __ ] themselves that's it
those people that are looking for that
golden age they're looking for that
holding hands and walking off into the
sunset the credits roll that doesn't
exist
it's not tattooed man it's not real i
thought it was tattoos i was like [ __ ]
i'm slipping
i'm like what i put all this repetition
i'm still slipping
can't take a day off man
can't take a day off man
no days can't take a day off seven days
a week
i i get after but see the thing about i
do active recovery right okay so what's
what's a light active recovery day you
say seven days seven miles is normal an
easy six mile run that's active recovery
at a low low heart rate i look like i'm
walking
i'm out to like a [ __ ] 9 30 10 minute
mile heart rates real low i'm really big
into the heart rate training man it's
amazing
so it makes you a machine
it makes you a machine man how so it
won't work it trains your heart
in a way that
the way i was able to run these 100-mile
races like i was able to do it was off a
heart rate
so if you go at 80
for me for the longest time it's like
100 like 147 heart rate 148 to 152 right
around in there if i maintain that man
i'm in that
i'm burning that nice fat storage
and that body wants to utilize that and
it wants to burn that nice and slow and
you're never getting that heart rate up
or high you can get the heart rate for
high it takes a lot to recover from that
and the higher it goes the longer it
takes for it to come down when i stayed
at 145 146 147 heart rate for a long
time when i get done running it will go
back under 100 within two or three
minutes
and that's what you want you want that
quick recovery
so quick recovery means that your body's
right on point and i look at my at my
heart rate in the morning time it's
using the 30s if it's like 45 46 47 i'm
over trained easy day
easy day means zone one zone one means
i'm just going real light today
so i train every day because why as a as
my mind and as a human we're supposed to
move
every day i'm supposed to move and i'm
not saying get after it every day get
after me just do something every day
right
ride a bike like if you're real tired
from working out hard ride an easy bike
spin and as you're spinning
take in your fluids
rehydrate your body as you're acting
because that's the best way to rehydrate
your body
and like taking a carbohydrate drink
it gets all that good carbs you start to
glycogen store your body again for the
next day
so as you're doing active stuff that
blood's flowing nice active blood flow
the nice active blood flow helps the
recovery process
along with drinking some some like
endurance drink or some carbohydrate
drink it gets all that glycogen through
the system back to the muscles loads
them back up again
ready to fight another war tomorrow what
do you use for a heart rate monitor i
used to use polar for a long time
um and i kind of still use polar now is
it a wrist one or a chest it's a chest
strap it's a nice cheap little chest
strap and now i'm at a point now where i
know
i only do my heart rate in the morning
time i don't even wear it when i run
anymore do you check it with the strap
in the morning or yeah your finger check
the strap so you wake up you just put
the strap on before you get out of bed
put the strap on your body
you don't first thing you do
put a strap on or
do your finger whatever one you can do
you don't have a strap do your finger
know what your average heart rate is you
know your resting heart rate and then
from there if it's a little bit high a
little elevated you know you can't go
off into that zone three zone four
training day you gotta keep it at zone
two or zone one
so it's all about the heart rate the the
resin heart rate so when you use it uh
the chest trap does it register on an
application on a phone like how do you
read it on the watch on a watch is it a
smart watch or is a polar watch it's a
polar watch so it's a watch that shows
you the heart rate that's reading off of
the strap exactly that's all it does and
so when you say zone ones this is these
are the things that you've created zone
ones onto the no these are like zones
that um that's you know whoever created
this like like the heart rate zone
training
so basically what i did in
what's helped me out so much is
my zone two training runs used to be 8
30.
okay so that was my pace at like uh 140
mile yep 830 mile
through stretching
and getting my body opened up
my zone two run now is about a seven
twenty one seven eighteen seven nineteen
so you cut a minute off just by opening
up your range of motion up my range of
motion wow unbelie at the same exact
heart rate so my stride if people look
at videos of me like years ago when i
was first doing my first bad water look
i was scooting i had like it was so
tight i looked i was this this very
rigid runner
now i actually run
you know everything was so tight
everything was like kind of like forming
in i was like kind of like like my knees
and my joints just going inward and now
everything's right you know where it
needs to be at and i have a nice long
nice stride do you run on the street are
you the most part for the most part i'm
always traveling
so the best thing you do you got your
running shoes you get your [ __ ] you just
go out and run but i i try to hit the
trails you know some dirt as much as
possible yeah so this is really good for
your body but now my body is like
[ __ ] it's like [ __ ] like iron
i mean it it it can take some beating
now when you when you run have you ever
[ __ ] with those uh barefoot running
shoes or minimalism no no
hell no hell no you know what like look
honestly i don't know many people who
have been
i just don't believe in it i don't
believe in it i've i was born with shoes
wearing shoes my whole [ __ ] life i'm
not
you know i'm black but i'm not from
africa you know
so
i'm not down man i'm not down dear ever
read the science behind it yeah the idea
of like using all the muscles on your
feet yeah i read the science behind it i
also read sometimes [ __ ] have
broken feet and [ __ ]
i read that too but minimalist shoes on
trails aren't bad yeah they're not i'm
not doing it no no no i will break my oh
my god man i'm running those things all
the time really so so you like them yeah
i it would kill me but i tell you what i
ran in uh fat tires yesterday under
armour fat tire which is like a cushiony
ass shoe you like it and i was like it
was so easy it's like it's like those
hocus
whatever no no uh under armour has these
fat tires it's basically like uh a bmx
tire track i think it's even made by a
tire company makes the tread
yeah man it's like it's got a mush to it
and you you're running these things man
you could run over see the thing about
those five finger barefoot shoes right
i like running those but you got to look
where you're stepping you can't step on
any hard rocks game yeah over you'll
[ __ ] up your foot yeah quick because
it's like it's going to go right in your
foot it's a tiny little thin so i went
from those to vivos vivo barefoot shoes
that's what it looks like
so when you run on those [ __ ] that is
a cushiony glorious
padding like when you when you hit the
ground it's like smooshy smooshy smush i
had the other ones jamie the ones with
the boa it's because it just like got
that little click one that you just
pulled up yeah like those so it's like
you twist it with that that's how you
tighten it up with that little boa uh
adjuster thing it's like a got a thread
through it so you don't have to lace it
or anything like that you just slip them
on and pop that sucker down i like to
feel the ground a little bit when i run
yeah you're barely feeling [ __ ] with
those yeah
that's clown yeah but i like it it's
gotta be good for your joints
my joints didn't bother me at all
yesterday which is crazy like after a
good solid run because most of what i'm
running is hills right like pretty steep
and it's great my ass and leg's never
been what do you weigh right now 200
yeah you're thick dude man yeah so for
me the pounding of the
you know the the constant pounding with
the feet to the ground it is uh it's
it's rough on the ankles it's rough on
you know the the joints but i don't feel
it at all with those fat tires it was
smooshy like i i got done running i felt
like i cheated
i did i felt like wow this is so much
easier the cloud shoes yeah this just
real cushioning and cam's always said
that he runs with those a lot oh does he
yeah he's run with a bunch of those like
he's like because he runs so many
[ __ ] miles he was running a marathon
a day
like pretty much every day i did that
for a while bad bad bad i was
sh
my god i got wired in doing that [ __ ]
man what is this right here
so this is
this is when i ran um i ran 150 mile
trail race
so the year before
i did the same race it's 150 mile trail
race i did it in i think around uh 40
hours and i had to walk the last 60
miles kind of i i had pneumonia here we
go yeah
and then i told the race director
hey [ __ ] i'm coming back here
next year and i'm breaking the course
record i went back and then like 32
hours
wow same race
wow
now no when you 33 hours so when you're
running what what shoes do you use
right now i'm wearing brooks and i also
wear um asics so it just depends on you
know what kind of train i'm in where i'm
at stuff like that for trails what do
you what run for trails i actually for
the longest time i wore a street running
shoe
really for trails yeah for the longest
time how come because first of all my
body was so messed up the only shoe i
could ever wear was this brooks
addiction and i hate even giving brooks
credit right now because back in the day
they wouldn't help a brother out i was
running so many miles yeah so brooks i'm
not trying to i'm not promoting brooks
right now
yeah merry christmas on that one
i caught him up a million times hey man
can i get like a discount or some [ __ ]
hang up nobody nothing so but they do
have a good shoe
and i uh and i and it was not good pr
horrible pr man you know what i'm saying
like you know so
but um yeah i love their shoe the only
thing i could wear was that brook's
addiction because my my bio mechanics
was so messed up i tried so many
different shoes and and that was a so i
can now wear a neutral shoe so how i
used to run and very few people know
this i used to have heel wedges
inserts heel wedges and
get compression tape
because my body was pushed so far in
from being so tight in my hip flexors
that so how i got such bad stress
fractures
was my bio mechanical there's a picture
of my toe in there because my my toes
just jammed in front of my shoes because
my whole body just got this
like bent in so you when you're saying
bent in for people just listening you're
if your hands are flat on a table you're
turning the outside of your hands in up
so that your thumbs are going down those
are my so yeah so that's those big toes
right going down or going down and into
the shoe and the outside of your foot
was up was above it right so what i had
to do to run because i was like god i
got stress fractures all the time
and my feet were so [ __ ] up sometimes
you see that with people's shoes like
how they're worn out worn out worn out
on the sideways example like a wedge
right can you look at it from behind
this crazy yeah that was my shoe so i
had to get a heel wedge
to keep my heel from going down got
severe tendonitis in the back of my
ankle
actually you had to make it thicker on
one side that's right just to force on
the inside flat right so the inside i
had to push up and i had to get
compression tape so it was compression
tape heel wedges
and an insert
and that's how i ran every [ __ ] day
did you go to a running coach or
anything did you i don't know
but didn't you want to know what you
were doing wrong you know what man that
was part of that garanimal mindset man
[ __ ] it man i'm supposed to be broken
you know
but then
i got smarter as time went and said oh
man this is some painful [ __ ] running
100 mile races with this kind of
tendinitis and my feet being [ __ ] up
it was so painful
so i was like you know what so then
after i started stretching
i was like my god all this was from
having a tight i got so massive my god i
was i was in all these different
contraptions
and now i just wear normal running shoes
wow yeah so i went from
being contraptioned up man
like literally contraption up so it's
all just the stretching that opened up
the range of motion
now when people talk about range of
motion they don't understand how tight i
was like no one understands like when
you repeatedly
do what i was doing to myself
and you were born with the stress i was
born under
like i hate i can't paint a clear it's
it's pretty clear in the book
man
my life was bad the stress i endured on
a daily i had two people
and my body was proof of literally
what my life was doing to me it
literally was
knotted all my muscles up because i was
always under this fight or flight you
know my my dad had made me so [ __ ]
scared of [ __ ]
you know to to unwind this [ __ ]
man was like
it was it was it was a hard task you
know i it was a hard it was a hard task
man so it's a lot of times it's not just
all the hard training no but it's also
the mind the mind because think about it
man when you're under stress
that hip flexor that that psoas muscle
which is attached to your t12
that that's the only muscle that
attaches your lower body to your upper
body
and that's the muscle that's that's your
fight or flight whenever you get nervous
or scared or something like that that
[ __ ] was tightened up i mean i
mean your whole body is
i lived in that like almost fetal
position in my mind
for so many years
so i was always on this like tight-knit
tension [ __ ] guy
but i walked around like i'm some cool
here's my new hairstyle
pants are sagging i'm a cool dude man
right but that was another costume the
costume wore every day yeah got tired of
running that [ __ ] man next
costume i want you to be in is a jiu
jitsu guy with a white belt on i'm going
to send you a picture man i got it i
know you're listening to the picture i
know you're gonna cause i already
planted that oh my god i know it's
bouncing around yeah it is it is i'm
gonna set it up nashville i know there's
some places out there nashville holler
at me
oh trust me
i'm sure they will we'll find you a spot
we'll have a funny spot um listen man
this book is [ __ ] fantastic i'm
halfway in i can't wait to finish it and
uh just thank you thank you for the
inspiration thank you for being so
honest and expressing yourself i
appreciate the [ __ ] out joe appreciate
you brother thanks again thank you
bye everybody
man thanks a lot brother
thank you so much
[Music]